[Musique]
messieurs dames bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet
s'appelle think ur view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
alors moi je suis valérie
masson-delmotte je suis chercheuse en
sciences du climat à l'université paris
saclay en banlieue sud de paris et je
suis aussi co présidente d'un des
groupes de travail du giec le groupe
intergouvernemental d'experts sur
l'évolution du climat et donc j'ai
récemment supervisé le rapport sur le
climat qui est sorti le 9 août dernier
et qui fait le point sur l'état des
connaissances qui donne finalement
l'image la plus clair qu'on a du climat
tel qu'il a varié dans le passé comment
il fonctionne comment il est en train de
changer aujourd'hui et les évolutions
futures possibles
j'ai un hutu moi je m'appelle donc
pierre larrouturou je suis ingénieur
agronome très engagé depuis longtemps
dans la lutte contre la pauvreté la
lutte contre le chômage et contre
l'exclusion et puis depuis sept ans j'ai
eu la chance de beaucoup travailler jean
jouzel qui est un des mes collègues et
amis de valérie à très grands
climatologues et puis depuis deux ans je
suis député européen rapporteur général
du budget au parlement européen et co
responsable du financement du climat ou
parlement européen donc j'étais dégoûté
les scientifiques et d'apporter des
solutions parce qu'il nous dise 'on la
verte et qu'il est temps qu'on passe à
l'action déferré 59 ans nous j'ai fait
une grève de la faim donc j'ai d'abord
fait voter un rapport par le parlement
européen qui dit que si on veut gagner
la bataille du climat il faudra isoler
les mais auront fort à faire des
transports en commun faudra aider les
agriculteurs tout ça c'est possible et
ça peut être génial on peut vivre dans
une société beaucoup plus équilibré on
peut encore éviter le chaos mais isoler
une maison c'est quarante mille euros on
va pas demander à chaque famille de
trouver 40000 euros faire des transports
en commun dans mon coin des pyrénées
tout le monde prend sa voiture parce que
pour aller au boulot il n'y a pas de
transports en commun on va mettre des
milliards dans les transports en commun
donc j'ai fait voter avec d'autres un
rapport qui dit comment on peut trouver
de l'argent en écoutant les gilet jaune
c'est pas en augmentant les impôts sur
ceux qui aiment milou 2000 par mois en
particulier en taxant la spéculation il
ya 70% des députés européens de toutes
les tendances qui ont voté ce rapport en
disant oui on peut taxer la spéculation
on peut mettre une taxe carbone aux
frontières pour aider les familles pour
faire l'isolation pour aider les
collectivités et j'ai vu que le lobby
banque a bloqué tout donc j'ai fait une
grève de la faim pendant 18 jours pour
dire on peut pas rester comme ça déjà
nicolas hulot quand il avait démissionné
avait tic le lobby lobby bancaire le
lobby pétrolier gêner son action et je
pense qu'il est important qu'un maximum
des citoyens comprennent vraiment les
enjeux et sachent qu'il ya des solutions
et que c'est pas grave si on demande une
taxe sur la spéculation les traders vont
pas en mourir sur leur prend 0,1 pour
cent on pourrait créer des millions
d'emplois et gagner la bataille du
climat valérie
jg étudiants un peu votre profil vous
êtes aussi peut être paléoclimatologue
en général quand on discute avec une
paléoclimatologue c'est soit dans un
scénario hollywoodien soit sur un
documentaire arte qu'on aime bien
regarder avant de s'endormir
donc en général quand on discute avec un
paléoclimatologue c'est que ça craint du
boudin
donc on va au vin on va aujourd'hui on
discutait un peu plus longuement
ce fameux rapport du giec qui sort c'est
le combi nîmes déjà c'est le sixième
cycle d'évaluation ça a démarré en 1990
donc en 1990 vous commenciez déjà tiré
la sonnette d'alarmé
la gg un peu investiguer sur vos
prospective sur la concentration savoir
que vous avez pu faire dans ce rapport
et ça craint vraiment quand on parle
d'un scénario à un degré 5 on est
actuellement sur un degré 5 c'est ça
d'augmentation de la température
mondiale alors en fait on en est à 1,1
degré à la surface de la terre
continents et océans celui moyenne par
rapport au s et ça c'est la moyenne
planétaire par rapport à 1850 1900 c'est
quelque chose qui en fait déjà massif
c'est une rupture par rapport à la
variabilité naturelle du climat au cours
des derniers de milan donc moi ce que je
reproche à un petit peu ça sera pour la
c'est dire 1.5 ou 1,1 degré c'est une
moyenne sur la terre mais sur les
continents ça veut dire plus que ça non
oui en fait le réchauffement il est plus
prononcée au dessus des continents que
la moyenne planétaire est
particulièrement marquée autour de
l'arctique donc en europe en france on
en est déjà en fait à un degré et demi
de réchauffement par rapport à la fin du
19e siècle et puis c'est pas seulement
une histoire de moyenne c'est une
histoire en fait d'un climat qui change
qui affecte aussi les conditions
météorologiques partout et donc
également des extrêmes chaud plus
fréquents et plus intenses en dés
evènement de précipitations intenses
plus intense plus fréquents on a vu cet
été à new york exactement c'est
également des cyclones tropicaux de
catégorie 3 5 plus fréquents c'est une
montée graduelle du niveau des mers
parce que les glaciers font parce que
l'océan gonflant parce que les kodaks
calotte de glace du groenland et de
l'antarctique s'écoule plus rapidement
la montée du niveau des mers elle a
accéléré au cours des derniers 30 ans et
c'est aussi une rupture sur plus de 3000
ans alors ici sur cette chaîne youtube
on a la chance d'avoir une communauté
qui se tient vraiment au fait de ce type
de données de data là j'aimerais qu'on
pousse le vice
en disant aux gens ce que ça comme
répercussions à court terme sur
l'approvisionnement nous
l'approvisionnement en énergie
l'approvisionnement en nourriture comme
le poisson ou la viande
la température qui va faire chez nous et
les répercussions sur nos
infrastructures les répercussions sur
notre système routière d'ailleurs on va
peut-être ont parlé avec pierre qu'est
ce que ça veut dire en termes de
migration par exemple un réchauffement
climatique sur un scénario à trois
degrés
alors je veux juste rappeler en fait ce
dont on parle donc on en est à 1,1 degré
notre meilleure estimation c'est que ce
réchauffement depuis en 1900 il est
intégralement due aux conséquences des
activités humaines avec des gaz à effet
de serre du dioxyde de carbone du
méthane et d'autres qui piège de la
chaleur qui part plus vers l'espace cet
effet là un petit peu masquées par
l'effet des particules de pollution
l'évolution future du climat elle n'est
pas actée elle n'est pas actée parce que
si on mettait tout à zéro aujourd'hui un
pour dix mille où il y aurait pas de
réchauffement supplémentaire en surface
la montée du niveau des mers l1 et les
inéluctable parce que avec le temps de
mélange dans les océans la réaction des
glaciers et des calottes qui vont
s'ajuster même au climat d'aujourd'hui
ça ça va continuer à monter le rythme va
aussi dépendre de l'ampleur du
réchauffement de surface et de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire un à horizon
des prochaines décennies yann une
poursuite de réchauffement qui va avoir
lieu pourquoi l'inertie c'est pas celle
du climat l'inertie c'est celle de nos
infrastructures les voitures les
systèmes de chauffage les usines
pratiques agricoles etc c'est ça qui
fait de lui si donc si on arrive à avoir
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui stagne au niveau actuel c'est à peu
près les promesses que les états ont mis
sur la table en 2015 des engagements
s'il se réalise des émissions qui stagne
jusqu'en 2030 si ça continue comme ça
quelques décennies on va dépasser un
degré et demi autour de 2020 et 2040 a
en moyenne sur une vingtaine d'années on
dépassera 2 degrés à horizon 2050 et
puis 3 degrés au début du prochain
siècle ça veut dire 6 degrés sur les
continents 3° ça veut dire davantage sur
les continents un réchauffement très
prononcé du côté de l'arctique ça veut
dire une accélération continue du rythme
de montée du niveau des mers des
événements show qui sont aujourd'hui
rares qui deviendront beaucoup plus
fréquents c'est en fait disproportionnée
par rapport aux niveaux de réchauffement
et pour donner un ordre de grandeur
si on prend le climat passé on est en
train de refaire une atmosphère en
rajoutant plein de gaz à effet de serre
en brûlant des énergies fossiles
qui a eu lieu à l'échelle géologique
le niveau de co2 dans l'atmosphère qui
augmentent du fait de nos activités
essentiellement charbon pétrole gaz
déforestation il atteint un niveau qui
la dernière fois qu'il a été connue
était il ya environ deux millions
d'années
la dernière fois qu'ils avaient un
niveau de réchauffement au tour d'audrey
et demi c'était il ya trois millions
d'années et pas l'espèce humaine telle
qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui et c'était
des changements en fait très graduelle
donc on est dans une situation où on est
aujourd'hui presque 8 milliards
d'humains
plutôt sédentaire la plupart d'entre
nous et donc l'ensemble des
caractéristiques d'un climat qui change
des tendances des extrêmes et puis des
valeurs qui dépassent des seuils de
tolérance ans pour les organismes pour
les espèces que l'on cultive pour nos
sociétés on le voit déjà on vit déjà
avec les impacts d'un climat qui change
sa touche toutes les régions et donc
plus le curseur sera important au niveau
planétaire plus en fait dans chaque
région en europe comme partout ailleurs
on devrait faire face à ces changements
complexes mais les risques c'est pas que
l'évolution du climat les risques c'est
aussi bas est-ce qu'on est
particulièrement vulnérable est-ce qu'on
est plus exposé quelles sont nos
capacités en fait anticipé à tenir
compte de cette information scientifique
par des pour développer des stratégies
de gestion de risques d'adaptation ont
déjà vos questions ci est ce qu on est
vulnérable louis 80 % soit 4 en france
deux tiers des gens qui sont directement
concernés par les aléas climatiques
parce qu on vit on vit sur des terrains
côtiers oui parce que va y avoir la
saline salinisation des sols par
capillarité l'eau de mer va remonter
dans les terres agricoles ont pour
appuyer sur place sans climatisation ou
sans vivre dans un trou est donc
revenons à la question initiale en terme
de chaîne alimentaire de chaîne
énergétique
et de chaîne d'approvisionnement en eau
quelles vont être les conséquences
les conséquences en fait elles vont
dépendre de ce qu'on pourra faire de ce
qu'on aura les capacités de faire en
termes d'adaptation est en fait dans
toutes les régions du monde on n'est pas
égaux par rapport à ça on n'a pas les
mêmes ressources on n'a pas les mêmes
compétences et donc l'enjeu en fait
c'est
si on regarde non pas la physique du
climat ce qui est le contenu de notre
rapport mais les conséquences les
impacts les risques les enjeux et touche
tous les secteurs d'activité alors je
vais donner un exemple celui de la
gestion de l'eau l'eau c'est vital en
fait donc dans un climat qui change le
réchauffement il est quasi globales par
contre les conséquences sur la
répartition des pluies elles sont très
hétérogènes dans les régions froides
c'est plus chaud et plus humide en
moyenne plus de précipitations en
moyenne annuelle par exemple plus de
pluie dans le nord de l'europe le nord
de la france en hiver plus de moustiques
plus de moyens plus de précipitations et
puis plus de pluies torrentielles
7% de plus de quantités de
précipitations sur les records par
degrés de réchauffement global donc ça
veut dire une augmentation du risque
d'inondation si on n'anticipe pas ça ça
peut être exacerbée dans les villes par
exemple parce que plus en urbanisme puis
ça ruisselle vite
mais dans les régions semi arides dans
les régions de climat méditerranéen dans
un climat qui se réchauffe il ya un
changement en fait de la circulation
atmosphérique de grande échelle est une
des conséquences c'est une baisse de la
quantité de pluie en moyenne annuelle et
en particulier pendant les saisons
sèches donc on le voit déjà autour de la
méditerranée et ça ne va faire que
s'accentuer à mesure du niveau de
réchauffe en global donc l'une des
conséquences directes c'est une
augmentation de la sévérité des
sécheresses et une des régions
particulièrement concernée c'est tout le
tourin rive nord rive sud de la
méditerranée présente millions de
personnes ça représente en fait des
dizaines de millions de personnes et par
ailleurs des populations qui sont
parfois très jeunes sur la rive sud de
la méditerranée
donc ça pose des questions
d'anticipation de la gestion de l'eau
d'une gestion durable de l'eau ça touche
bien sûr les pratiques agricoles mais
aussi l'approvisionnement pour
l'industrie et pour les villes donc ce
sont des enjeux qui sont extrêmement
importants en europe comme partout dans
le monde
et puis c'est pas simplement ça en fait
c'est pas que des moyennes donc le
dernier constat que l'on dresse avec
dans ce rapport pour la première fois un
chapitre entier dédié au cycle de l'eau
c'est que dans un climat qui se
réchauffe le cycle de l'eau en fête en
moyenne et s'intensifie vous ça veut
dire une atmosphère qui contient plus
d'humidité
parfois des épisodes plus intense en
moyenne plus on met des gaz à effet de
serre plus les pluies de mousson par
exemple sont intenses mais quand
l'atmosphère est plus chaude en fait
elle peut aussi vider plus vite les sols
de leur humidité en renforçant
l'évaporation la transpiration des
plantes et donc en fait ce dont on parle
c'est un cycle de l'eau plus intense +
variable + variable d'une année à
l'autre d'une saison à l'autre avec des
saisons très sèche très humide et des
événements très sec et très humide
exacerbée et c'est aussi le cas pour
l'europe de l'ouest si je vous comprends
bien se faire dès des événements plus
extrêmes cernon les chaînes alimentaires
exactement donc on avait rendu en 2019
un rapport spécial sur les enjeux
croisés climat sécurité alimentaire donc
le constat il est très nette quand on a
par exemple des sécheresses sévères qui
touche certaines régions où des vagues
de chaleur qui dépassent les seuils de
tolérance des espèces cultivées ou des
animaux qu'on élève les animaux
d'élevage bande à des chutes de
rendement pour le moment c'est quelque
chose qui est plutôt concentré et qu'on
arrive à gérer par le marché mondial en
fait d'approvisionnement plus le climat
se réchauffe plus on risque d'avoir des
chocs mais qui sont pas seulement pour
une seule région mais qui pourrait
toucher plusieurs grenier à blé en même
temps donc ça ça fait partie des enjeux
critiques par exemple pour l'europe dans
notre analyse montre que à + 2 degrés on
risque en fait de souvent dépassés les
seuils de tolérance qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui pour la santé pour le
travail en extérieur ou pour certaines
espèces cultivées aujourd'hui donc on
n'est pas complètement coincé au sens où
finalement les enjeux pour la sécurité
alimentaire s'est pas simplement le
niveau de réchauffement c'est aussi en
fait l'évolution des revenus des
agriculteurs partout dans le monde si en
fait on les aide à sortir de la pauvreté
si on renforce leur capacité
d'adaptation
c'est ça permet de réduire ce risque et
d'un autre côté si on maîtrise la
demande alimentaire on peut aussi
limiter les risques la demande
alimentaire s'est tiré par eux
l'évolution démographique
ils détruisent l'alimentation est ce
qu'on doit maîtriser l'évolution
démographique
nous on explore en fait un ensemble de
scénarios très contrastées pour
l'appareil il fait de bons jeux pourront
pas répondre à une question ça en fait
je décris ce qu'on fait
pour le climat pour comprendre comment
un climat va évoluer on explore en fait
c'est un grand scénario c'est une grande
famille scénario très contrastées le je
vais décrire les deux extrêmes comme ça
ça donne une idée ces scénarios vous
avez inclut la cupidité des lobbys il
l'impuissance des politiques en fait
c'est vraiment des narratif complètement
contrasté donc on va prendre le scénario
curseur maximum sur la soutenabilité
donc forte volonté politique
mise en oeuvre de politiques publiques
pour la maîtrise démographique c'est
l'éducation des filles en particulier
maîtrise de la consommation donc des
modes de consommation soutenable pour
l'alimentation les matières premières
non renouvelables maîtrise de la demande
d'énergie ça c'est le scénario le plus
bas en fait en termes d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et c'est celui qui
permet d'assurer la sécurité alimentaire
même pour un réchauffement qui
atteindrait 2 degrés sans chocs majeurs
et puis des scénarios intermédiaires en
poursuite deux tendances actuelles et
puis des scénarios en fait deux
augmentations des rivalités régionales
un développement en fait tout bas la
population continue à augmenter et non
seulement elle augmente mais les
inégalités explosent donc ça veut dire
d'un côté une partie importante de la
population mondiale qui a les moyens en
fait de consommer beaucoup donc ça
exerce une pression très forte sur la
demande en matériaux la demande en
énergie ça exerce également une pression
très forte sur la demande alimentaire
partant de la consommation de viande ou
d'huile végétale donc qui exercent une
pression croissante sur les terres et
sur le climat et de l'autre côté une
partie importante de la population
mondiale qui est très pauvre très peu de
capacité d'adaptation pas de filet de
sécurité pas de système d'assurance
extrêmement vulnérables et donc en fait
en fonction de ces familles de scénario
les impacts sur le climat à travers les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre la
pression sur les terres et la
biodiversité sont très différents mais
aussi les vulnérabilités les expositions
les capacités à agir et donc nous on
regarde les faits climat et en février
nos collègues en fait qui travaille sur
les impacts les risques et les options
d'adaptation vont utiliser les mêmes
types d'informations pour avoir une
vision beaucoup plus clair sur
l'ensemble des risques par secteur par
région y compris les questions de
déplacement de population à l'intérieur
des pays entre les pays parce que bien
sûr cela fait partie aussi des enjeux je
vais vous poser une question
qui n'est pas très simple qu'est ce que
ça veut dire maîtrise et commence est
applicable je veux que ça vous fait
sourire
maîtrise dans la bouche d'un
scientifique je comprends mais dans la
bouche d'un politique ça se traduit
comment ça se traduit par une dictature
verte si je vais voir si jean ping judy
bon maîtrise ça veut dire quoi chez toi
il va me dire on sait faire
maîtrise en europe ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire des quotas ça veut dire on
vous envoie la police quand vote quand
vous faites n'importe quoi dans votre
entreprise on vous fait payer des
amendes
c'est quoi la maîtrise quand on dit
maîtrise de la démographie ça veut dire
quoi alors dans ces scénarios c'est par
exemple des choix politiques dans toutes
les régions du monde dans tous les pays
où ont choisi de mettre l'accent sur
l'accès à la santé reproductive
l'éducation des femmes le fait de
permettre par exemple d'avoir des
systèmes de sécurité sociale de retraite
qui permettent d'éviter de dépendre en
fait du nombre d'enfants qu'on a pour
assurer ses vieux jours c'est des choses
de ce type la maîtrise de la demande en
matériaux par exemple ben ça peut être
comme en norvège le choix par exemple
sur les véhicules de taxer les véhicules
en fonction de leur masse par exemple de
sorte à encourager ceux qui vont acheter
des véhicules plus léger dont
l'empreinte à la production ils plus
réduite que ce que des tanks en fait
voilà donc en fait les formes de
l'implémentation peuvent être très
variées selon le type de pays la
gouvernance le niveau de développement
aussi du pays nous en fait pour la
partie disons évolution du climat global
physique du climat ce qui compte pour
nous en fait c'est la manière dont ça
agit au niveau planétaire sur les
échanges de rayonnement entre la terre
et l'espace et puis sur les puits de
carbone c'est-à-dire la capacité des
sols de la dg tation à absorber une
partie de nos rejets de gaz à effet de
serre en tant que scientifique vous
pensez que nos politiques sont à même de
gérer ça quand on voit qu'ils ont pas
été capable de maintenir un stock de
masques un stock de casaque un stock de
quoi que ce soit nous là la cinquième ou
sixième puissance mondiale est-ce que
vous pensez que le réchauffement
climatique en fait ça va faire faire un
burn-out à toute notre classe politique
alors je vais parler franchement
effectivement la pandémie elle a montré
que devant une situation qui était
diététique inédite on va dire mais qui
était attendu les rapports de l'om s sur
l'occurrence de nouvelles zones aux il
était déjà là je nous aurais maladie qui
passent des animaux aux humains équipes
qui peuvent se répand très vite au
niveau mondial on en a vu une quoi sinon
industriel way est par ailleurs
les systèmes de gestion d' alerte etc on
a vu que les différents pays du monde
n'était pas au même niveau et certains
pays asiatiques qui avaient déjà eu un
coronavirus il ya quelques années il
avait mis en place des systèmes en fait
de réaction des stocks et sera un peu
différente de ce qu'on avait dans
d'autres régions du monde donc ça montre
en fait l'importance des dispositifs de
préparation la culture de gestion de
risque l'anticipation et quand on n'est
pas prêt bacon à un événement de ce type
là qui se produit on est le dos au mur
on doit prendre des mesures brutales et
de privation de liberté et ça fait un an
et demi qu'on vit avec ça et donc ce qui
vous attend récuse les mains pour la
question climat le constat scientifique
il n'est pas tout jeune en fait le
premier rapport qui décrit comment le
crime a réagi quand on rajoute des gaz à
effet de serre le les degrés de
réchauffement si on double la teneur en
co2 de l'atmosphère c'est un rapport de
l'académie des sciences américaine le
premier café inca construit un consensus
scientifique de 1970
ce constat en fait il a été renforcée
rendue de plus en plus robustes au cours
du temps et dans le dernier rapport de
cet été on a pour la première fois une
estimation plus précise d'ailleurs de
cette sensibilité du climat en combinant
toutes les sources d'information la
compréhension de chaque boucle de
rétroaction ce qu'on ne tire des
observations récentes ce qu'on tire des
crimes à passer donc on a une meilleure
estimation et une plage qui a été divisé
par deux par rapport à ce qu'on savait à
la fin des années 70 mais quand on
regarde du côté du monde politique moi
ce qui me frappe c'est l'inertie alors
dans les exemples l'inertie ce que ça
qui vous frappe maintenant dans les
exemples d'inertie c'est par exemple est
ce qu'il ya eu des plans de formation
dans les administrations publiques de
sorte à ce que les éléments de
connaissances scientifiques sur deux
dimensions les enjeux et puis les
actions à mener et comment les mener je
vais accomplir n'a pas j'ai compris le
départ des actions de en fait les
actions de formation ou d'accord il ya
un défi nouveau camp des pour entrer
dans la fonction publique faut avoir
fait le collège nous là on est en train
on est en train de parler de l'action
publique d'accord après on peut remonter
sur la formation et l'éducation est trop
basse mais simplement sur l'action
publique
la formation des fonctionnaires en fait
ceux qui sont chargés de mener les
politiques publiques on peut aussi
parler de la formation des élus sur ces
questions là je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses à renforcer
dans cette année le gouvernement
français met en place un tronc commun de
formation pour les écoles de la fonction
publique de la haute fonction publique
sur un certain nombre d'enjeux dont les
enjeux climat pour la première fois on
est en 2021 si on prend les programmes
maintenant plus en amont c'est pas
simplement ceux qui mènent les
politiques publiques mais c'est aussi la
formation de tout un chacun en fait à
l'école au collège ou au lycée il ya
encore beaucoup à faire et si ça monte
en fait sur la sensibilisation on va
dire sur les enjeux climat biodiversité
à l'école primaire au collège au lycée
il ya un tas d'enseignants qui font un
travail formidable ce qui manque je
pense aujourd'hui c'est là que le fait
d'acquérir des compétences pour agir pas
simplement de comprendre vaguement les
enjeux et agir c'est quoi c'est utiliser
des informations scientifiques pour
pouvoir anticiper et limiter les
conséquences négatives d'un climat qui
change donc dix dents les vulnérabilités
l'exposition aux aléas climatiques et
agir pour le réduire et puis oui je
pense que c'est possible il ya des
retours d'expérience de différentes
régions du monde de conte poésie en coin
non ça peut être le cas par exemple en
chine ou dans certains secteurs aux
états unis sont chine ou dans d'autres
régions européennes finissent pasqua il
ya la prise de conscience d'une grande
vulnérabilité
disons-le un rapport à un climat qui
change et donc il ya des enjeux par
exemple d'accès à l'eau
d'approvisionnement non quand ils ont vu
leur titre i bien qui était devenue
violette
bon ils ont dû quand même voir passer un
reer ya toute une réflexion et la chine
elle a subi une urbanisation très rapide
comme beaucoup de pays émergents et les
villes et les exacerbe à la fois les
effets des vagues de chaleur et puis
elle exacerbe aussi le ruissellement de
l'eau donc il ya toute une réflexion sur
transformer les vielles en en faisant
des éponges par exemple de sorte à
pouvoir amortir l'effet de pluies
torrentielles c'est un exemple de
réflexion qui a lieu en chine qui a lu
ailleurs voilà donc dans toutes les
régions du monde il ya des retours
d'expérience mais si on prend le cas de
la france ou de l'europe je pense que
sur la question de l'adaptation c'est à
dire pas regarder dans le rétroviseur
pas se dire je vais gérer les risques en
regardant ce qui s'est passé il ya
trente ans il ya cent ans mais quels
sont les événements nouveaux inédits en
quoi cela me concerne et qu'est-ce que
je peux faire pour en limiter la casse
ça c'est pas encore fait et s'est pas
fait par exemple dans les plans de
prévention des risques aujourd'hui on
regarde dans le rétroviseur et on
n'intègre pas cette information sur des
risques nouveaux eux pourtant connu pour
lui si le système financier un peu mal
connaissez comment ça fonctionne le
système financier à court terme à court
terme c'est ce pour résumer trivialement
notre système financier il repousse sur
quoi
ont posé la question à moins sur la
rentabilité sur la terre sur une
fonction exponentielle oui
passer la parole à pierre juste après je
moi je vous poserai jaune fait
l'internet sur le monde de la finance ce
qui monte en puissance par rapport à mon
domaine à moi qui est celui de la
physique du climat c'est le bullshit de
co2 non c'est l'utilisation
d'informations climatique fine pour être
capable de faire des stress tests et en
particulier le secteur des actuaires
c'est les gestionnaires de risques et
chaque fois qu'il ya un gros projets
d'investissement
infrastructures critiques il évalue en
fait les risques associés à ces
investissements est de plus en plus il
utilise cette information là vous les
actuaires travaille beaucoup avec les
assureurs et grâce à de la big data ils
sont capables de dire toi tu vas payer
plus cher son assurance parce que tu as
17 cm - ou que ton voisin donc tu vas
avoir un mètre cinquante de flotte en
plus donc ça serait bien qu'il ya des
enjeux majeurs dans cette heure par
l'ong le système de mutualisation de
risque avec la gestion des dispositifs
catastrophes naturelles est-ce qu'il va
tenir avec un climat qui se réchauffe et
c'est pas seulement les grosses est
extrême c'est aussi des sécheresses
modérée + frais content avec des enjeux
majeurs avec les mouvements de sol sur
le bâti existant et ça ça demande une
réflexion de fond pour pas avoir une
exacerbation des inégalités et que
chacun soit laissé seul devant des coûts
et des dommages un croissant c'est le
cas en france c'est le cas partout dans
le monde a commenté internet sur la
bétonisation essonne exemple récent des
joutes 2024 destruction des jardins
d'aubervilliers pour un solarium pour
les athlètes en tant que scientifique
préféré solarium où les petits potagers
aubervilliers personnellement c'est pas
en tant que scientifique que j'ai un
avis là dessus c'est en tant que
citoyenne dans ton que citoyenne en tant
que citoyenne je pense qu en particulier
dans un contexte de pandémie avoir accès
à des espaces verts et une convivialité
liées à la production de légumes c'est
plutôt bien
pierre je partage cette opinion comme
s'il fallait aussi pardon un peu
financés écologie quand on voit un
système financier qui fait de la
cavalerie à longueur de dany qui nous
fait du mundo dressing pour nous mettre
des lunettes roses à longueur d'année
que tout va bien et que c'est bien géré
et que nos banques nous dise que tout va
bien que les fonds de garantie des
dépôts bancaires vont tout régler en k2
en quatre petites crises n'être que
l'état fait un effet de levier sur le
fonds de garantie des dépôts bancaires
ou kalou engage sa signature pour
pouvoir protéger votre épargne hauteur
de 72 mille euros par compte et par
établissement bancaire est ce que tu
penses
qu'on va s'en sortir entre des
politiques qui sont les rois du skull
tâche d'air chaud et de brassage de
fumer un système financier qui est
gangréné par des intérêts nécessitant de
faire des pressions à gauche ou à droite
ou de changer des lois pour pouvoir
survivre quand on voit par exemple
l'italie faire pression en disant vous
comprenez lamborghini ferrari sont pas
prêts à faire la transition tout de
suite
on va où la pierre parce que tu es
politiques doisneau je suis un citoyen
et depuis les puits j'essaye de faire
bouger les politiques et je suis moi
même politique et j'ai même peut-être
candidat à la présidentielle elle la
primaire populaire mais effectivement
valais c'est compliqué de parler après
valérie parce que c'est vraiment le plus
important encore non mais là encore
plein de choses à dire mais voilà c'est
compliqué de passer voilà juste
effectivement on va pas s'en sortir a
priori c'est foutu s'il ya pas une
réaction massive des citoyens voilà et
si on continue effectivement à compter
sur les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
si on continue à compter sur le il ya un
énorme risque qu'on aille vers la
catastrophe et dans 20 ans ce sera trop
tard on sera sur le toboggan tous les
tous que les climatologues nous aurons
dit ça va se réaliser et c'est plutôt en
train de s'accélérer et on va tous se
détester on va tous se détestant dans
mes [__] et on a été nuls on a été nuls
on était au courant il nous en dit des
choses très précises la nature nous a
envoyé plein de messages 700 morts au
canada cet été dans les canicules 700
morts 200 morts en belgique en allemagne
des débats là donc il faut être ne pas
lire les journaux il faut même au moins
le rapport peut-être tout le monde doit
pallier des 300 pages pas combien de
temps mais au moins les condensés pour
décideurs mais la plupart de nos
dirigeants ne le lisent pas je voyais
encore à me dionne notre climatologues
qui me dit qu'il était effaré par
l'incapacité des dirigeants à le
comprendre donc et valérie l'a très bien
expliqué ce n'est pas juste un petit
réchauffement la température moyenne qui
augmente de 1 degré ou 1,5 degré ce sont
des événements climatiques extrêmes qui
se multiplient tu parlais des sociétés
d'assurance et une courbe qui est assez
impressionnante que j'ai montré à jour
un ambassadeur qui il m'avait dit qu'il
est que 20 minutes j'ai commencé avec
cette cour là il m'a gardé une heure et
demie à mon cerveau doudou je ne
donnerai pas son nom mais c'est un
monsieur très important à bruxelles
monsieur voilà je lis le taux n'en
auraient pas le nom parce qu'on crée des
relations une croyance du pays un pays
d'europe voilà non mais c'est juste pour
déconner dans ces événements le nombre à
bruxelles y parle parce que tous
français le nombre d'événements
climatiques extrêmes a déjà été
multiplié par 2,5 voilà les événements
climatiques extrêmes c'est les grandes
canicules c'est les inondations dont
valérie parlé c'était quoi il ya cinq
ans il ya des inondations à paris
c'était rigolo on allait voir la scène
qui débordé pour les parisiens c'était
rigolo mais la récolte de blé a perdu -1
32% en france en belgique -32%
heureusement que l'ukraine on a tous
appris dans nos cours de svt qui a deux
greniers qui nourrissent de grands
greniers qui nourrit europe heureusement
que l'ukraine n'a pas été touché par les
mêmes d'inondations parce que si la même
année on a la france belgique et
l'ukraine qu'ils ont touchées par les
inondations ou par une grosse canicule
une canicule au mois de juin elle
empêche le grain de blé de se remplir et
bien honorer des tickets de rationnement
on est comme des petits mammifères on
est on est tous contents de faire deux
ou trois repas par jour et le stock de
céréales il ne représente pas un tiers
de la consommation annuelle donc si on a
dans les deux zones où deux années de
suite on peut avoir de très gros
problèmes à nos graphiques que je
voulais vous montrer c'est aussi ce que
nous disent les climatologues c'est si
on continue comme ça dans trente ans
qu'on va amorcer des années 2050 on aura
de plus en plus c'est canicules à
répétition le corps humain il est fait
pour fonctionner à 37 degrés s'il fait
40 degrés on se met à l'ombre on boit de
l'eau on évite voilà mais si on nous
explique qu'il y aura souvent des
canicules qui pour monter à 54
météo-france taudis des canicules qui
monteront à 54 55 degrés et c'est tous
les 2 ou 3 ans 56 le joueur 56 oui
dedans le whip dans 55 degrés dans la
partie de l'est de la france voilà et
c'est pas c'est pas dans trois siècles
c'est à partir de 2050 2060 si on
continue à faire du blabla et à ne rien
changer radicalement et ce qui m'énerve
c'est que pour le moment on ne change
rien et de damnés de dernier graphique
c'est tout ce qui vous expliquent dans
mais c'est juste pour illustrer quand
les climatologues parle des cercles de
reto des boucles de rétroaction les
cercles vicieux dans le langage certains
vous disent au moins avec le virus le
co2 ça s'est calmé toutes nos économies
ont été à l'arrêt et c'est vrai que le
co2 qui vient de nos de nos usines de
nos camions à diminué en 2020 c'est vrai
mais les feux de forêt ont pris une
telle ampleur les feux de forêt en
australie 440 morts en australie ça
c'est en californie en californie voyait
tous les grands feux de forêt depuis 90
ans
l'année 2020 une seule année
représentent un tiers des surfaces
cramer donc le co2 qui est mesuré amont
à l'oas je suis honteux de parler de ça
devant toi tu connais ça mille fois
mieux que moi mais je le vois au
parlement européen des gens qui à deux
ans de mise et oui le climat c'est
important et qui maintenant disent oh
non non c'est bon le client peut
attendre un peu parce qu'au moins avec
le virus à ses calmes et jusqu'ici ça
qu'ils disent y compris une partie de la
droite du groupe du groupe du ppe qui
était d'accord il ya deux ans qui avait
applaudi le discours de madame en raion
pas dire le climat est notre priorité et
qui maintenant nous disent écoutez ce au
moins avec le virus de co2 s'est calmé
donc je le répète très calmement en
france comme en allemagne le co2 qui
vient de nos industries et de nos
voitures a baissé de 8% l'an dernier
mais le co2 qu'il ya des feux de forêt
des feux de forêt en sibérie quand
j'étais petit faisait froid en sibérie
donc ça tape ça fait plus que compenser
et le co2 comme mesure dans l'ensemble
de l'atmosphère amont aloi il ya hélas
aucun ralentissement peut couper oui
bien sûr valérie j'te vois de diniz de
tête ouais deux choses donc dans un
climat qui se réchauffe des extrêmes
chaud plus fréquents et plus intenses
dans certaines régions une augmentation
des des sécheresses vous croisez l'e2c
des conditions propices aux incendies
qui sont fréquentes sur des saisons plus
longue sur des régions nous venons vous
en france on le voit partout ailleurs
donc c'est un est un des effets d'un
climat qui se réchauffe alors pour
l'instant c'est pas quelque chose qui
est dominant sur le cycle du carbone
donc ce nom mais 40 milliards de tonnes
de co2 dans l'atmosphère et l'océan la
végétation les sols sont le récupère à
peu près la moitié c'est à peu près
stable depuis 50 ans par contre ce
service qui nous rendent ces 56 % ce
service que l'océan la végétation les
sols nous rendent ce sera limité dans un
climat qui se réchauffe si on continue à
déverser des quantités colossales et
croissantes de co2 dans ce cas là en
fait les puits naturels de carbone vont
continuer à augmenter mais ils seront
proportionnellement moins efficace et un
gros point d'interrogation c'est
effectivement les faits seuls plus chaud
avec plus de respiration des sols et
fait des feux de forêt sur le puits de
carbone terrestre commentaires internet
le problème des forêts privées qui
éjecte plus de co2 qui n'en absorbe pour
l'interrogation
alors les forêts primaires jusqu'à
présent stocks du carbone et qui
s'accumulent en fait qui se décompose 1
dans le sol dans l'eure là les racines
etc par contre avec une dégradation de
certaines forêts du fait des pressions
locales par exemple au brésil ou
ailleurs là en fait on peut perdre la
capacité de stockage de certaines forêts
avec en plus les effets climat et je
vais dire un mot sur la pandémie donc il
faut imaginer l'atmosphère c'est une
baignoire nous on a ouvert grand le
robinet un croissant et on déverse des
quantités colossales de co2 dans cette
baignoire on a une partie qui repart
océan végétation et sol la pandémie
c'est quoi on prend les mêmes
infrastructures on les utilise - surtout
les transports un peu les usines donc au
niveau mondial c'est en gros 5 % - sur
le débit qui en est reparti à la hausse
1 l'effet rebond il est déjà là
l'économie en chine ailleurs elle
accélère et donc du coup on a réduit le
débit de ce qu'on met dans l'atmosphère
qui en auraient augmenté le niveau dans
la baignoire avec continue à monter le
niveau du co2 dans l'atmosphère et
continuer à monter pour avoir un effet
mesurable c'est pas quelques mois c'est
part annoncé une baisse de plusieurs
pourcents des émissions partout dans le
monde chaque année et là on enverra
assez vite les bénéfices sur la
composition de l'atmosphère sur la
qualité de l'air mais il faudra attendre
quasiment une vingtaine d'années pour en
voir les effets sur le climat bien
désolé tellement coupé non mais c'est
pour ça qu'il faut maintenant prendre
les décisions c'est 8 pour illustrer que
le problème n'est pas linéaire à ta
question c'était sur les dirigeants
politiques la plupart des dirigeants
politiques ont l'habitude de gérer les
problèmes de façon linéaire il arrive au
pouvoir en général ils savent qu'ils ont
cinq ans et puis il faut une réforme ou
deux puis laisseront le bazar au
successeur qui laissera le bazar au
successeur est en général au pouvoir moi
je ils n'ont pas le temps de réfléchir
de prendre voilà hélas oui mais quand
même ils vous reçoivent donc ils n'ont
qu'une je trouve ils n'ont aucune excuse
donc et engrange un point juste pour
illustrer je suis là pour apporter des
graphiques illustrent ce qui
confirmerait dit valérie c'est vraiment
scandaleux pour être poli l'inertie nos
dirigeants parce que si le giec a été
créée il ya 33 ou 34 ans à peu près
c'est qu'il y avait déjà quasiment un
consensus des scientifiques voilà et que
à la une du new york times en cas en
juin 88 à la une du new york times il ya
la courbe de sur le réchauffement
climatique
parce que la veille un grand
scientifique un de tes collègues avaient
été reçus au sénat y avait scotché tout
le monde parle hélas ça le fait un bâton
dans son argumentaire était archi
convaincant donc déjà en 88 il y avait
quasiment inconsciente à y avait un
consensus de quasiment tous les
scientifiques et qui dès qu'il était
encore possible qu'on avait 20 ans pour
sortir des énergies des énergies
pétrolière mais qui est que c'était une
pause tout à fait possible et le lobby
pétrolier tous les lobbys ont tout fait
pour dire peut être que oui peut être
que non plus tard quand maintenant il
est urgent de dire il n'est pas trop
tard pour agir je vois aussi des gens
qui sont prêts à se flinguer qui pensent
que c'est foutu qu'on va dire le chaos
je vois y compris dans la génération des
enfants des jeunes qui déprime complète
fort heureusement des jeunes qui sont
dans la rue et qui nous aident pour
éveiller les plus vieux mais il ya aussi
certains qui pensent que c'est foutu
qu'ils auront une vie de merde entre le
dérèglement climatique les fondements de
la biodiversité le chômage la précarité
les voilà donc moi si je suis ici comme
de toi c'est que je pense qu'il n'est
pas trop tard mais qu'on n'a pas quinze
ans pour réfléchir avec la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on sait ce qu'il faut
faire tout le travail qui a été fait par
les climatologues maintenant le
diagnostic est super précis quand claude
allègre effet son bouquin plein de
mensonges valérie et quelques autres
femmes et hommes scientifique avis on
peut pas accepter n'importe quoi et donc
vous aviez opté je crois que tu as vu un
rôle important valérie pour obtenir que
l'académie des sciences face ainsi moi
tranquille non pas s'engueuler devant
des caméras mais il ya eu six mois
passionnant à l'académie des sciences et
à la fin le pauvre claude allègre avait
dû bouffer son chapeau parce que lui
même avait voté un texte qui disait donc
à l'unanimité l'académie des sciences et
vie dit il n'ya plus aucun doute sur la
réalité du réchauffement climatique et
le fait que le réchauffement climatique
polk la quasi-totalité bien des
activités humaines et c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle parce que vous aviez que
senoussi nous sommes responsables on est
capable d'agir c'est pas comme la fin
des dinosaures les pauvres dinosaures
scène astéroïde deux énormes c'est mille
fois c'est un milliard de fois hiroshima
donc l'époque dinosaures même si tu as
vu un cerveau un peu plus s'il avait été
plus futés il ne pouvait rien faire il
n'était pas responsable du problème et
une fois qu'il a eu le choc c'était
foutu tandis que là nous sommes
responsables de ces émissions de co2 de
méthane et donc il est possible de
changer nos modes de vie et ça suppose
une firme d'avocats d'utiliser suppose
une volonté politique et des
financements massifs jeu mais on y
reviendra quand tu ne prendras les
politiques dans la même phrase quand
même déculottée non mais la volonté
politique ça peut être aussi que les
citoyens pousse les politiques à bouger
d'accord parce que certains politiques
n'ont pas compris le problème et
d'autres sont effarés par l'immensité sa
femme voilà et un parallèle qu'on peut
faire c'est jules ferry certains disent
et il est temps que le condamne les que
l'éducation gratuite à tous les enfants
en france d'autres disais c'est pas
possible pays n'est pas encore assez
riche donc les citoyens ont foutu une
pression on ne sait pas assez mais il ya
eu un million cinq cent mille
personnes qui ont signé la pétition pour
demander à jules ferry qui est l'école
laïque gratuite et obligatoire 1500000
pétition en voyant qu'ils remontent des
charrettes à paris alors à l'époque y
avait pas internet donc pour être un peu
moins cool époque nous et oui voilà et
donc ils demandent à jules-ferry qu'on
fasse cette loi pour dire que l'école
est libre et laïque et gratuite et
obligatoire et après ça pendant 20 ans
le pays se transforme partout dans
n'importe quel village de bretagne où
des pyrénées ont fait l'école des
garçons l'école les filles la maison
pour les mettre en forme des milliers
d'instituteurs d'hommes et on veut
évidemment c'est un énorme bazar
évidemment s'engueulent entre
l'architecte et le maire qui sont pas
toujours d'accord mais ce qu'on retient
c'est que en 20 ans en vingt ans la
france a réussi le pari de faire de
l'éducation pour tous et que derrière on
a tous profiter alors certains pensaient
que c'était une idée utopique pareil
quand kennedy on va bientôt fêter les 60
ans du beau discours de we choose to go
to the moon nous avons décidé d'aller
sur la lune certains pensent que kennedy
et frappadingue mais il a décidé
effectivement pour des raisons
politiques pour vous d'aller sur la lune
il y met les moyens on va créer 400
mille emplois le kennedy je raconte
c'est le jour au parlement européen
kennedy il sort le chéquier on va être
multiplié par 15 le but est de la nasa
il crée quatre cent mille emplois et on
est capable d'envoyer des gens sur la
lune plus vite que ce que pensaient
kennedy donc là sur la question du
climat est ce qu'on a compris la gravité
on va dire des scènes d'horreur nos
enfants vont nous détester sauvage il
est sûr qu'on serait vivre dans une
société soutenue
mais les scènes d'europe alors moi je
suis ici j'ai fait la grève de la faim
et a dit alors j'ai fait deux grèves de
la faim si je suis vraiment engagé comme
d'autres valérie passe des mois des
nocturnes pour faire les rapports du
giec qui travaille je le dis on y passe
et les scientifiques une fois tu m'avais
dit que ton mari parti d'en haut en
antarctique faut faire des prélèvements
parfois vous travailler dans des
conditions très difficiles physiquement
est appréciable ils passent des mois
pour vérifier que toutes les
informations sont juste voilà mais et
c'est donc mais moi si je suis comme
d'autres engagés sur le climat s'est en
particulier avait passé deux jours à
bamako au mali et j'avais vraiment été
frappé après ça il m'a fallu plusieurs
semaines pour retrouver le sommeil parce
que les scientifiques de bamako qui
m'avait invité à parler du sida
climatique il ne parlait pas du
réchauffement climatique il parlait du
sida climatique en détention ne fait
rien et bien le dérèglement climatique
va faire autant de morts que le vih que
le sida l'un des jeunes scientifiques
étaient là son papa était avait un
troupeau au sahel il me donne en tout le
monde s'en faut mais la sécheresse
convient en sont au sahel c'est la plus
grave sécheresse jamais vu depuis 1600
ans ou de milan et je voyais des scènes
d'horreur quand je suis revenu je
faisais des cauchemars envoyé cette
photo très connu au vietnam une petite
fille qui traversent des flammes
derrière concrètement ça veut dire quoi
quand valérie qui aura des problèmes
d'accès à l'eau la banque mondiale dit
que vous l'avez faudi cas des grandes
régions d'afrique où les récoltes vont
être divisés par deux voilà parce que
quand l'eau arrivera elle sera de façon
très violente elle ne rentre pas bien
dans les sols et quel pays a des
périodes de sécheresse donc globalement
il faudrait détaillé l'afrique c'est
immense il ya plusieurs scénarios mais
globalement un des scénarios les plus
probables c'est des récoltes qui sont
divisées par deux d'ici 30 ans sur ne
fait rien si on ne fait rien des
récoltes divisé par deux alors que la
population va doubler donc il n'y a pas
besoin d'être un génie pour comprendre
le problème s'il ya deux fois moins de
nourriture et deux fois plus de
population on n'a pas encore parlé des
pointes de la chaleur humide souvenez
vous quand nicolas hulot a démissionné
il a dit la terre devient une étuve mon
ami nicolas qu'à une émission à trois
reprises dans sur france inter il dit la
terre devient une étuve le motif n'est
pas par hasard là aujourd'hui on avait
tous très chaud à paris 31 degrés mais
je pense n'y a pas eu de mort parce que
le corps humain est fait pour évaporer
on boit de l'eau et on évapore est comme
ça on est à 37 degrés le cerveau le foie
ne
disjoncte pas mais si l'air est trop
humide ce site elle ne marche plus et
donc même si vous buvez de l'eau vous
n'arrivez plus il leur est en même temps
chaud et humide vous n'arrivez plus à
évaporer et le corps monte en
température et en trois heures c'est
foutu les pompiers ne peuvent rien faire
pour vous et donc le m haïti nous dit
que il ya des grandes zones est lassé
des zones très peuplées une zone d'étude
giamatti qui était sorti juste avant que
nicolas hulot donne sa démission elle
disait que des zones de poux il y avait
350 millions de chinois allait avoir si
on ne faisait rien je le répète on ne
sait rien allez avoir des étés chauds
des périodes chaudes chaud et humide
qu'une grande partie de l'arabie ce
serait pareil qu'une partie de l'afrique
si on ne fait rien et donc si vous dites
à des gens dans 20 ans votre terre vous
risquez de crever alors vous même vous
pouvez pas mettre la climatisation
crever douce et cela vous risquez de
mourir fond vous allez souffrir un jour
j attends mon but n'est pas d'inciter
chose qui va pas moi mon but est de dire
prêt payant nous nos pays ont déjà été
capables de réussir des gens de
challenge c'était d'école pour tous
c'était de faire le métro tout le monde
se foutait de quand vous arrivez à mon
père m'a s'appelle montparnasse
bienvenüe c'est un breton que monsieur
bienvenus quand il a il s'est dit il
faut qu'on fasse un métro les ouvriers
n'arrive pas à se déplacer dans des
bonnes conditions faut faire un métro à
paris selon ledit coûteux fait 50 ans
qu'on en parle il ya des lobbys qui
bloque ça tu te fatigues pour rien et
bienvenue est un peu têtu il a réussi à
convaincre en voilà et en quelques
années on a réussi à faire le méchant
couche tout stoop donc si elle volonté
politique et si on m a les moyens
financiers
ça va être un joyeux bazar mon a les
moyens d'isoler les maisons isolées tous
les bâtiments publics et privés de faire
des transports en commun d'inventer des
voitures qui consomment moins d'aider
les agriculteurs à changer leurs
pratiques et on peut rattraper le temps
perdu tout le temps qu'on appela de
risoul et les maisons étaient venus en
début d'année il incarne plus 40% sur
les matières premières pour les
habitations ça arrive bien se passer je
vais faire c'est pour ça qu'il faut le
planifier excuse moi c'est pour ça que
je parle quand travailler des gens du
bâtiment ils disent que c'est tout à
fait faisable mais il faut se donner un
calendrier sur 20 ans c'est pour ça
qu'au niveau du parlement européen on ne
demande qu'à des financements chante
maintenant que chaque famille sache
qu'elle aura des airs joués teulé sa
maison et du coup le secteur du bâtiment
il va recruter 300 mille personnes on va
les former on sait qu'on aura du boulot
pendant 20 ans je lis je te lis un
commentaire que j'attrape haut vol a
commenté internet commentaire de chiba
il dit c'est pas mal de ne pas sombrer
dans le désespoir et de dire qu'il y à
un plomb mais à combien % de réussite
qu'il pense que son plan va marcher
honnêtement sachant qu'il faut que tout
le monde anti le suivent dans l'état
actuel du monde donc je développe un peu
ça son commentaire
on y tous à couteaux tirés dans la
guerre économique
celui qui refuse de l'accepter et soit
borgne soit un menteur
il est doucement bercé par le langage
diplomatique aussi doux que ronronnant
mais derrière il faut dire qu'on est
tous les couteaux tirés entre leurs
ailes le renseignement économique
l'espionnage économique le renseignement
invasif je vais très vulgaire mais il
écoute les coups de couteau dans le dos
de nos propres alliés sur nos marchés
comment veux tu que
ce scénario avec des lunettes roses on
va se donner la main on va prendre
conscience que tout va mal qu'on est sur
le mauvais chemin alors que quand le
giec sort son rapport le seul truc qui
fait la une c'est le transfert de messi
et quoi d'autre
le pass sanitaire en france parce que
lionel messi est arrivé à paris c'est
quand même un événement important mais
par moi j'étais en espagne eh bien tous
les journaux espagnols même les plus
conservateurs ont fait des pages
entières sur le rapport du giec avec les
feux de forêt en turquie et en algérie
donc je crois qu'une évolution des
mentalités il ya quatre ans avec jean
jouzel on était invité pour l'événement
de rentrée de tous les jeunes
agriculteurs de france des milliers
s'appelle terre de gym à fougères en en
bretagne les milliers de jeunes
agriculteurs qui venait là pour échanger
pendant trois jours et le grand débat de
l'après midi c'était que peut faire
l'europe pour sauver le climat et
l'agriculteur qui lançait le débat
disait ce débat était inimaginable il ya
dix ans il ya dix ans tous les
agriculteurs étaient climato-sceptiques
claude allègre était notre danse et qui
disait claude allègre était notre héros
et les écolos nous casser les pieds
voilà et puis là quand il ya une
inondation qui fait que nos amis qui
vont du blé ont perdu 30 % de la récolte
et puis après ça il ya trois années de
suite où il ya des canicules et de
sécheresses ce qui fait que ceux qui
sont éleveurs dans l'est de la france
qui vont tuer une partie du troupeau
parce que quand tu as des canicules
pendant deux années ou trois années de
suite tu manges du foin tu manges du
froid et puis une fois le prix du x
augmente et donc à des agriculteurs qui
doivent tuer une partie de leurs bêtes
et donc l'agriculteur disait maintenant
il n'y a plus aucun climato sceptiques
chez les agriculteurs la question est de
savoir comment est ce qu'on fait là la
transformation est donc j'ai expliqué
qu'elle était le plan qu'on avait pour
trouver de l'argent au niveau européen
sont taxés monsieur madame tout le monde
on en voit là c'était avant le gilet
jaune dans savait déjà qu'il ya une
demande de justice fiscale au bout du
coût de ses missions et eksi benon
pardon aussi contacter la spéculation je
sais pas si tu as beaucoup d'action moi
j'ai zéro action voilà donc il ya 85 %
des français qui n'ont aucune action et
il y en a trois pour cent par contre
qu'ils paient ou un pur sang qui circule
comme des cochons le nombre de
milliardaires a triplé en dix ans je
vais pas je venais voilà on peut
demander un effort quand j'ai fait ma
grève de la faim j'ai eu et nicolas
hulot edgar morin qui m'ont soutenu mais
le trust et des climatologues mais même
un des plus grandes banquier belge un
des plus grands banquiers belge est venu
à de la surprise en disant qu'il parlait
à titre personnel mais que effectivement
demandé 0,1 pour cent de prendre 0 1%
sur les transactions financières
s'étaient pas la mort je rappelle pour
ceux et celles qui nous écoutent le
principe c'est que
du diable
du bon dieu ça de ses enfants voilà en
disant que l'idée c'est tout simple
d'une taxe sur la spéculation c'est que
le taux normal de tva quand on achète un
téléphone quand on achète n'importe quoi
c'est 20 % 20 % le taux réduit pour que
les gens les plus pauvres puissent
manger quelqu'un qui sdf cas il aura
cumulé 5 euros il va aller chez
carrefour ou chez leclerc pour cela il
va payer 15 5 5% de tva même les plus
pauvres pour manger paye 5 5% de tva et
sur les marchés financiers ces
000 points 0 est-ce que c'est des gens
encore plus pauvres que les sdf est ce
que c'est encore plus important que de
manger non c'est juste que le lobby
bancaire bloque tout ça et donc on a je
répète 70% des députés ont voté ce
rapport et j'ai fait la grève de la faim
pour expliquer que c'était possible de
trouver de trouver ses sous et donc cela
permettrait en même temps de créer
massivement des emplois si on a de
l'argent qui arrive pour isoler les
maisons sûres d'elles d'argent pour les
transports en commun dans mon coin des
pyrénées il y avait pas mal gilet jaune
et je les comprends très bien parce que
si tu es du boulot à pierrefitte ou
argelès tout le monde doit prendre sa
voiture il n'y a pas de transports en
commun bien organisés et les gens sont
conscients du problème climatique pas
d'enjeu fini j'étais parti je les jeunes
agriculteurs est rude moi tu m'as poser
une autre question la conclusion c'est
que les jeunes agriculteurs disait
maintenant tout le monde a compris la
gravité du problème climatique et on en
souffre et on voit là et simplement par
an pour faire et le gars qui même avait
invité ou qui a animé le débat disait
moi je suis éleveur je sais que le
lisier de mes animaux ils abîment la
nappe phréatique et qu'il abîme
l'atmosphère mais je sais que maintenant
on peut faire du biogaz que c'est
efficace mais l'investissement dans le
biogaz ces cinq cent mille euros la
plupart des paysans n'arrivent pas à se
verser le smic n'arrive pas à gagner
1000 euros par mois donc on va pas leur
demander un investissement de 500 milles
il dit par contre si à des aides
européennes qu'ils payent au moins la
moitié ou les trois quarts de la somme
et qu'on sait qu'on est un débouché eh
bien ce n'est que trois ou quatre
collègues agriculteurs ont créé un ou
deux emplois c'est le faire revenus
supplémentaires donc la question de
comment des blocs sur la caisse de la
convention citoyenne j'en avais parlé à
quelques mois 150 citoyens et valérie
d'autres lits matelas ou les avait
beaucoup aidé à réfléchir 150 citoyens
qui venaient de toute la france qui
était représentative de toute la
population française au début il y en a
qui n'en avait rien à [__] du climat
mais juste en prenant deux jours ou
trois jours de réflexion avec les
climatologues il ya eu ils ont tous
compris ils ont débouché sur ils ont
débouché sur des solutions et hélas le
vainement nuls et n'a pas repris
l'essentiel de ses propositions donc
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
[__] un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière j'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'il y avait une primaire populaire
voilà on a tout fait pour être clair il
ya des moments où valérie dit qu'elle
parle à titre perso donc moi aussi je
parle comme citoyen on a tout fait
depuis quatre ans pour que emmanuel
macron et son équipe fasse des choses
sur le climat la biodiversité
c'est une radicalisation pire dans nos
débuts on ya cru quand il a créé le haut
conseil pour le climat en effet le one
planet ce mythe je me suis dit je suis
pas d'accord avec sa politique
économique et fiscale mais sur le climat
il de faire des choses et là on a vu que
même quand 150 citoyens font des
propositions très concrètes
emmanuel macron avait promis il avait
promis qu'il allait reprendre 146
proposition et même le conseil d'état
dit qu'il n'a rien repris vous avez vu
que le conseil d'état deux reprises dit
qu'on est complètement à côté de la
plaque donc je pense qu'il faut que
cette équipe qui arrive à faire une
équipe il ya une primaire populaire tous
ceux qui nous écoutent vous prenez sur
le site primaire populaire point fr cela
n'arrive pas à se rassembler on
n'arrivera pas à voir une autre équipe
qui arrive au pouvoir l'année prochaine
alors que si on arrive au pouvoir mois
d'avril prochain au mois d'avril
prochain les élections présidentielles
on peut dès le mois de mai faire un
sommet européen extraordinaire
ce sera la présidence française je
rappelle je suis député européen
rapporteur général du budget je vais
encore ce matin à bruxelles avant de
revenir pour vous rencontrer donc je
suis persuadé que c'est la france qui
bloque tu quand tu m'avais donné la
parole j'avais montré même la lettre du
ministre autrichien des finances
pourtant un homme de droite qui disait
que l'autriche était d'accord pour taxer
la spéculation mais si c'était la
version française qui l'emporté
l'autriche se retirer la salle des
négociations si j'étais mal gré de la
fin c'était parce que parce que tout le
monde dit c'est la france qui bloque
quatre à quatre reprises en un mois non
pas d'en dire et je m'en fous de sauver
l'honneur je veux que faire bouger les
choses des dirigeants allemands monde y
perd on est d'accord le conseiller le
conseiller climat dans gala merkel qui
me dit pierre ce n'est pas d'un pas
d'insister je suis un fan de la taxe sur
la spéculation je vous rappelle que
merkel en 2014 est allé à londres pour
dit aux anglais arrêtez votre veto il
faut créer la taxe sur la spéculation
angela merkel aurait voulu un accord sur
la taxe sur la spéculation et c'est la
france qui a bloqué donc si on arrive à
avoir la primaire populaire si on arrive
à se rassembler je sais pas si je vais
gagner aussi chevret numéro 3 numéro 8
il faut une équipe il ya aucun homme
aucune femme providentiel il faut faire
une équipe avec un projet très clair et
dire si on gagne au mois d'avril
dès le mois de mai ont fait un sommet
européen on habite tous les chefs d'état
européens dans la maison de jean monnet
on prend trois jeux tous les sujets qui
étaient bloqués par la france comme la
taxe sur la spéculation ou comme la
sortie des énergies fossiles on donne un
nouveau départ à l'europe et dès le mois
de juillet ont fait voter la loi climat
qui était préparé par la convention
citoyenne on reprend l'intégralité on
reprend l'intégralité des propositions
proposé par la convention citoyenne
parce qu'on aurait eu d accord sur un
financement et l'on sait que l'argent va
arriver au bout d'un an donc moi j'y
crois vraiment j'ai tout fait je si
j'étais méchant je montrerai les sms qui
emmanuel macron m'a envoyé je crois ton
projet voyons-nous tant aidé et on veut
prendre son du bureau de téléphonie je
ne donnerais pas mais voilà donc
maintenant il ya des pays où les gens se
font tuer pour avoir des élections
démocratiques
nous on est d'un pays à des élections
démocratiques dont on en profite on est
nul je l' ai dit l'autre jour j'étais
dans une réunion avec yannick jadot avec
hidalgo avec julien bayou écoliers fort
je leur ai dit mais on est nul à chier
désolé d'être vulgaire mais je leur ai
dit on est nuls nos enfants vont nous
détester nos enfants vont nous jeter des
cailloux ce n'est pas capable de se
rassembler au lit et d'avoir une autre
politique ouais donc là c'est un autre
sujet c'est pas un sujet scientifique
c'est un sujet d'implémentation finale
c'est toujours un deux projets
intéressants des landes scientifique et
citoyenne moi je lis toujours
attentivement les programmes les
promesses électorales à mon angle au
climat je les lui pour les régionales et
municipales je vais le lire pour les
présidentielles on ne les jeunes joueurs
mais son temps j'ai un espoir c'est que
les journalistes politiques qui vont
interviewer tous les candidats pleins
fait une pléthore il leur pose des
questions très précises par rapport à
leurs plans d'action concrets pourquoi
parce que la france elle s'engage comme
l'europe avec à atteindre la neutralité
carbone à horizon 2050 c'est quelque
chose qui est important mais la question
c'est pour que ça se produise il faut
démarrer maintenant je peux de stopper
oui ok
un exemple tout tout tout ces tombereaux
d'argent public qui ont été données à
des entreprises pour déployer d'aider
des projets de captation co2 y a pas un
qui loue qui a été qui a été depuis cinq
ans il n'y a pas un qui loue qui a été
re capter alors tout tout tout tout tout
l'argent parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
bouche it washingto à l'écologie le
chiffre d'affaires tesla qui est
intimement lié aux crédits co2 qui vont
sur les marchés toutes les boîtes qui
font des pseudos aux innovations pour le
climat il ya beaucoup de bullshit ça va
même pour les faux sont les fausses
listes yves de machine à laver
l'état y vas faire quoi un autre exemple
dans deux ans l'union européenne va
imposer aux pays et aux entreprises qui
ont plus de 250 salariés de publier
leurs informations sur la consommation
d'où la consommation électrique
tu as vu la même chose oui d'accord moi
je t'ai dit secret des affaires
je veux pas publier ma consommation
d'eau parce que secret des affaires ça
va donner les des éléments pour que mon
concurrent me2me des boîtes sur les
marchés qu'est ce qu'on va faire les
scientifiques et les politiques ils vont
faire quoi ils vont appeler les
scientifiques qui vont dire maintenant
vous allez contrôler ce que publient les
entreprises qui ont l'habitude de
pipeauté autant que sur leur bilan
et j'en passe il va faire quoi les
politiques qui vont à temps ils vont
faire des petites lois qui vont jamais
pouvoir être respectée et est-ce qu'à la
fin on va pas se retrouver avec une
dictature verte est-ce qu'on va pas se
retrouver avec une société complètement
totalitaire parce que là là c'était la
belle fête on avait la calorie
accessible accessible facilement l'eau
accessible facilement les transports
accessibles facilement les soins tout
facile et là on va se retrouver la mère
ce recul même si le niveau des océans
monte mais la mère circuler et on est
tous en short nous infrastructures sont
pas prêtes encaisser le choc à très
court terme nos infrastructures de
transport nous infrastructure financière
nos infrastructures alimentaire et j'en
passe moi quand je vous écoute
je trouve ça aussi pertinent qu'un filet
d'eau tiède c'est à dire vous avez des
données qui sont vrais tous les deux des
des constats qui sont vraies mais vous
n'êtes pas assez radicaliser
il faut arrêter de faire des rapports ou
à lui sixième rapport là on est au
courant qu'on est sur un scénario
complètement morbide donc arrêtez de
faire des rapports fait une grève de la
faim au giec là vous arrêtez tous deux
becqueter
et puis et puis in fine et c'est ce qui
va arriver alors moi ma position c'est
de miser sur l'intelligence collective
et je vais le dire aux gens ce que le
non non je le dis franchement il ya un
intérêt sur ces enjeux pour s'approprier
des éléments provoquant jeu dans tous
les secteurs de son code de la route non
non je recommence il ya un intérêt qui
est croissant c'est à dire autant il ya
une lenteur des élus de certains aspects
politiques pour s'approprier ces
éléments et construire une vision de
l'intégrer à une vision avoir des
projets ambitieux de transformation
autant dans l'ensemble de la société
civile pour moi sa bouche de tous les
côtés j'interviens dans des écoles
d'ingénieurs j'interviens dans des
universités des écoles dans différentes
formations c'est incroyable en fait
l'envi un d'agir quand elle était
intervenue sur l'université de grenoble
tafer 14,8 vu l'envié d'agir après
l'autre chose de trois mois les
sollicitations qu'on a pour ce nouveau
rapport du giec moi j'étais là pour ça
tu m'a invité pour ça les sollicitations
c'est dans le secteur des entreprises et
pas simplement parce que ras des
inventaires à faire parce qu'il ya un
tas de gens dans les entreprises qui
veulent que ce soit pas que du
greenwashing quelque chose qui fait joli
mais quelque chose de structurant
pourquoi parce que ce dont on parle et
en particulier en europe c'est des
transformations dans tous les secteurs
d'activité l'énergie les infrastructures
dans les villes
c'est également des transformations
complète dans les systèmes agricoles et
alimentaires sains profonde et puis
c'est des enjeux en fait de
compétitivité des entreprises terre
celle qui vont arriver avec des choses
crédible sérieuse qui happe qui
permettent des avancées majeures elles
seront aux avant-postes la compétitivité
c'est pas toxique pour le climat pour ça
sert la performance du service qui est
rendue je parle pas de purement
rentabilité financière ou économique
mais le développement d'un service
nouveau c'est quelque chose qui va bien
sûr créé des opportunités importantes
l'autre pression dans les entreprises on
me l'a dit à de très nombreuses reprises
c'est la capacité à garder les gens
brillants cerci en entreprise elle
contribue à émettre toujours plus de gaz
à effet de serre on cache ans a derrière
des trucs joli ça se voit en fait ça se
voit ça se voit de plus en plus
clairement et dans ce cas là les gens
qui cherchent un sens à leur travail ont
envie de mettre leurs compétences leur
énergie leur dynamisme au service
d'autres choses il cherche en fait à
portée des solutions ici dans une
entreprise ce que les mercenaires c'est
à dire ce qu'ils en restent là que parce
qu'ils sont payés ce qui suppose
notamment nettement les partis
politiques non ça marche nettement moins
bien et donc non et donc ce que je veux
dire je fréquente pas de parti politique
en fait noté mon côté
des gens convaincus mais ce que je
voulais dire l'absence d'accord voilà
mais ce que je voulais dire là dessus
c'est il ya un rôle bien sûr pour
l'action politique il ya un rôle au
niveau européen il ya un rôle au niveau
national il ya un rôle au niveau des
régions au niveau des villes et un rôle
important les leviers d'action sont pas
les mêmes par exemple les régions elles
ont vraiment un rôle de chef de file de
l'action pour le climat par rapport à la
formation par rapport aux
investissements aux transports aux
politiques économiques
au niveau européen il ya un enjeu qui
est important c'est aussi celui des
échanges internationaux et du fait de
rentrer et la question climat dans les
traités commerciaux internationaux et
c'est particulièrement important pour la
france parce que nous en fait on a
beaucoup d industrialiser beaucoup perdu
l'emploi associé à ça et si on prend les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
personne en france en quasiment la
moitié donc nos émissions c'est en gros
10 tonnes de co2 équivalent par personne
et par an sa baisse sur la partie
nationale mais sur l'empreinte net quand
on regarde ce qu'on importe de pays qui
produisent les choses avec du charbon ça
stagne donc la question de exercer
et on a des leviers d'action par exemple
dans les entreprises s'ils rendent plus
transparentes en l'empreinte associés
aux chaînes de valeur s'ils exercent des
pressions sur leurs partenaires
commerciaux en europe de l'est ou en
asie ça a un effet s'il ya des règles
commerciales s'il ya une fiscalité par
exemple aux frontières aligné avec
l'accord de paris sur le climat par
exemple ça peut avoir un effet qui est
important il faut pas le sous-estimer il
faut pas sous-estimer en fait la
capacité aussi des entreprises à porter
des transformations mais le cadre
réglementaire le cadre fiscal il est
bien sûr très important et a mis le
doigt sur un truc fondamentale on a
parlé tout à l'heure du fait que agir
pour le climat ça coûte cher ça demande
des ressources sa demande d
investissement mais d'un autre côté ne
pas agir laisser l'évolution du climat
toutes les analyses montrent que ça va
être un démultiplicateur des inégalités
comme réduire les réduire les lits
d'hôpitaux avant une pandémie c'est ça
non si j'ai bien compris que c'est moins
immédiat je dirais c'est plus
structurelle c'est réduire les lits
d'hôpitaux y laisser les inférieur à
1500 au sens assez dégoûté des gens
d'être infirmière voilà par exemple oui
donc en fait la question c'est si on
n'agit pas pour maîtriser l'ampleur du
changement climatique c'est clair que ça
va exacerber les inégalités partout dans
le monde et en tout premier lieu dans
les pays de la bande tropicale où les
effets aujourd'hui sont les plus forts
en fait hein c'est là où on est déjà
sorti de la variabilité naturelle pour
pas mal de choses et après donc la
question c'est vraiment comment on
arrive à mener des transformations
profondes structurantes qui soit juste
qui soit juste qu'il soit perçue comme
juste ça ça demande aussi des modalités
de prise de décision différente ça
demande des processus par exemple
participatif c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
bien aimé l'exemple de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat il ya eu
l'équivalent au royaume uni il ya eu
l'équivalent en irlande l'assemblée
citoyenne et ce qui est frappant c'est
qu'à chaque fois quand on fait ça et
c'est aussi le cas dans plein de régions
des citoyens de tous horizons politiques
qui représente un peu la société dans
toute sa diversité en fait un de
formation d'avis de bio de vie de
revenus tout le reste l'envy d'agir par
rapport aux choses qui tiennent au coeur
des gens ce qu'ils ont envie de
conserver ce qu'ils ont envie de
transmettre qui sont prêts à changer
c'est nettement en avance par rapport à
la tiédeur en fait des promesses
politiques et puis de leur réalisation
c'est quelque chose qui est très frappe
ce changement de paradigme
moi je le vois différemment
là on veut non j'ai vu un gamin de
cartes 14 ans pieds nus en train de
faire la manche
j'ai vu un bidonville dans le nord de
paris j'ai vu je ne sais pas combien de
chiens abandonnés j'ai vu je ne sais pas
combien d'infraction est ce que notre
société n'est pas trop violente pour
prendre conscience de ça est-ce que nous
notre société occidentale
on n'est pas trop intoxiqué par les
énergies fossiles par la cupidité
latéralité les connards qui vont faire
d'évasion fiscale au qatar
des influenceurs j'en passe et des
meilleurs est-ce qu'on n'est pas tombé
donc comment faire sam
une société tellement schizophrénique
que voir un pire la route ou une
scientifique renommé nous dire les
choses en face en fait ce soir de
nouveau messi est lé nouveau machin
et je crois que non non je crois que je
me fais la moue qui vient d'expliquer je
crois si moi je reste un petit peu
optimiste je crois qu'on est des
millions à vouloir vivre autrement
effectivement à se dire visiblement ça
va pas bien des grands chefs donc
prenons nos responsabilités si un jour
tu viens me voir au parlement européen
derrière moi j'ai une très belle photo
du mur du berlin qui est en train de
tomber et j'ai fini mes études à
sciences po en avril 89 est le plus
grand spécialiste de l'allemagne nous a
dit que le mur de berlin est encore là
pendant 50 ans il ya une version sous ce
nom pardon
témérité gens ce problème et donc il en
était persuadé le mur de berlin n'allait
pas tomber avant 50 ans et cinq mois
plus tard le mur de berlin est tombé
mais c'est pas à gorbatchev ou le
moonwalk ils ont décidé ces des citoyens
et la photo est magnifique on va des
jeunes et puis quelques mois jamais
qu'ils font tomber le mur de berlin pas
si justin en avait marre de ce mode de
vie voulait vivre libre et je crois
qu'on est des millions à lire et à
comprendre ce que dit le giec n'est
aussi avoir les canicules qui se répète
avoir qu'on va vers un monde vers le
chaos alors qu'on ne pourrait vivre
heureux on a tout pour vivre heureux et
quand il ya un choix à faire visiblement
c'est pas nos dirigeants qui vont le
faire donc il faut qu'on les pousse et
qu'on profite je le répète des
prochaines élections leur veulerie a
suivi avant tout à l'heure j'ai pas
répondu candide un monde de plus en plus
violents depuis un bureau en compétition
aussi la france est la seule à bouger
d'abord je rappelle quand même que la
france et l'europe c'est quand même une
des deux premières puissances
économiques mondiales donc si nous on le
fait c'est quand même pas marginal et je
crois que la question du climat est
peut-être la meilleure façon de parler
de fraternité de façon très concrète ça
m'a frappé au dernier sommet climat là
il ya bientôt glasgow le grand sommet
mais à madrid il ya 18 mois c'était
émouvant de voir des femmes malgaches
qui parle avec des irakiens avaient des
israéliens avaient des indiens des
chinois des gens de tous les milieux le
climat est le seul truc qui intéresse
aussi bien des gens archi riche dans des
camps des maisons à 3 millions à los
angeles et les pauvres d'inde du
bangladesh parce que tout le monde est
concerné par le climat personne peut se
dire moi ça m'arrivera jamais les 700
personnes qui sont mortes au canada il y
avait des pauvres il y avait des riches
il y avait donc je crois que le climat
est peut-être le seul truc agir ensemble
pour le climat c'est peut-être le seul
sujet qui peut rassembler des israéliens
des palestiniens des fils wade a dit
voilà donc quand il n'y aura par des
tensions mais ça peut être un objectif
qui nous rassemble et je l'en tête je
comprends ce que tu dis je comprends ce
que tu dis est en même temps ce que ce
que je vois aussi s'est il ya pour moi
une prise de conscience mondiale pas
simplement parce qu'il ya des rapports
scientifiques mais aussi parce que les
gens ils voile il voit la réalité des
effets d'un climat qui change il ya
également une prise de conscience que
même si on a des revenus élevés même si
on est dans un pays plus riche qu'un
autre on est concerné aussi et on n'est
pas prêt voilà donc il ya cette prise de
conscience qui est là partout je pense
et souvent ce qui manque c'est quand on
a envie d'agir comment agir comment agir
de manière efficace comment agir pas
seul mais de manière collective donc ce
que tu décris c'est un des exemples d'un
cadre qui permet d'agir ensemble il ya
eu plein de jeunes qui aiment curité
marché il ya quelques années dans les
rues démarches pour le climat etc et
quand je re discute avec eux ce qui me
dit c'est maintenant nous on veut des
compétences on veut avoir un cadre
professionnel ou on n'est pas simplement
en train de marcher puis dire ça va pas
mais on apporte des solutions concrètes
donc la difficulté c'est d'arriver à
coordonner sa à le rendre visible pour
surmonter l'espèce d'inertie que tu
décris est autant il ya quelques années
il y avait des discours de dénis par
rapport à l'ampleur des enjeux climat
s'est encore là pour la biodiversité
pourtant les enjeux sont considérables
et encore des discours de dénis de
l'importance de de garder des
écosystèmes en bonne santé mais ce qu'on
voit de plus en plus c'est des discours
d'inaction c'est à dire c'est trop
difficile il faut attendre que des
technologies soient là il faudrait des
solutions politiques parfaite donc on a
un fait à surmonter ses discours de d2
d'inaction qui sont de plus en plus
présent j'ai été très frappée quand j'ai
sur les réseaux sociaux sur twitter j'ai
partagé certains aspects du rapport du
giec et puis il ya eu un article dans le
monde d'un journaliste scientifique qui
a fait de la provocation en dix ans mais
à quoi ça sert à quoi il sert puisque
finalement ça fait 30 ans qu'il ya des
rapports et puis les émissions de gaz à
effet serre continuent à augmenter donc
j'ai posé la question est-ce que vous
l'utilisez j'ai eu peu de réponses du
monde politique mais beaucoup de
réponses de citoyens d'enseignants de
deux personnes qui travaillent dans
plein de cadres professionnels
différents qu'ils disent oui moi
j'utilise ça j'utilise ça parce que je
veux comprendre les enjeux je veux
savoir à quoi m'attendre je veux pouvoir
anticiper je veux pouvoir en tenir
compte dans ma vie professionnelle ça
c'est nouveau ce n'était pas le cas il
ya cinq ans ce n'était pas le cas il ya
10 ans
de la même manière en 12e non je pense
qu'il ya un mouvement de fond est un
mouvement de fond mais avec encore des
essais de génération par exemple les
plus jeunes parfois ont grandi avec ça
ils ont baigné dedans en fait pour eux
c'est une évidence mais pour certains
qui sont en fait beaucoup aux manettes
c'est encore quelque chose qui est un
peu à la périphérie des priorités des
enjeux importants stratégique de prise
de décision et ce qu'on voit aussi c'est
que que ce soit au niveau des élus que
ce soit au niveau des décideurs dans les
entreprises en fait ce qui arrive qu'ils
intègrent vraiment dans leur vision des
choses et qui s'entoure des gens
brillants il arrive à changer les choses
très vite donc c'est pour ça que je dis
moi je crois vraiment à cette forme
d'intelligence collective qu'on a vu
aussi dans le contexte de la pandémie
quand ben ouannes a bien vu que
préparation de l'état n'était pas là il
ya plein de gens en fait qui se sont
entraidés qui ont trouvé des solutions à
un tas de problèmes nouveaux ensembles
voilà et donc moi je crois beaucoup à ça
mais je crois aussi que si on avait des
journalistes politiques ni informé sur
les questions climat qui pose des
questions pertinentes aux personnalités
politiques qui les interrogent pas
simplement le blabla mais concrètement
le plan d'action un an à deux ans quels
objectifs pour la baisse des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre est ce que les
lois elles tiennent le cap des
engagements qu'on sait donner ou pas ça
ferait monter le niveau d'exigence pour
tout le monde et cette année c'est
particulièrement critique à me dire que
les journalistes en fait on peut le loup
sur les journalistes politiques qui
interroge les personnalités politiques
sur leurs promesses et leurs engagements
les plans d'actions non sur le soulman
je te rassure sur les causes disparaît
pire ce nom ça me parait golay parce que
là c'est effectivement si on entend
quelques banques certains médias
mainstream c'est essentiellement la
petite phrase c'est darmanin qui répond
à la petite salle de valérie pécresse
pour fou de l'huile sur le feu et on
oublie les grandes questions
fondamentales à leurs couches et les
français j'aurai peut être dit valérie
et une perception la question du climat
j'ai vu une enquête un peu sérieuse où
près de 30000 personnes qui dit qu'après
les questions de vie le virus et la
santé de la question du climat est le
problème numéro un bien devant les
problèmes c'est que même s'il voit une
sécurité sont importants donc il ya une
perception et c'est je répète d'un pays
depuis en plus morcelé c'est sans doute
un des sujets qui peut si on n'agit qui
peut rassembler tout le monde il ya
trois ans bien avant d'être député
européen on avait fait un événement à
jussieu pour présenter on avait des
juristes avaient rédigé le traité
européen qu'on veut pour créer une
banque du climat que l'argent à la
banque centrale au lieu d'aller à la
spéculation qu'il ait su aller on
voulait créer une banque du climat et on
voulait avoir des ressources pour aider
chaque famille et des chats
collectivités on était 1000 personnes à
jussieu il y avait aussi bien alain
juppé ou laurence parisot du medef que
les gens d'alternatiba ou des patrons
des syndicats le conseiller du pape et
des vannes on avait ceux qui croient au
ciel et ceux qui n'y croit pas on avait
des jeunes et des vieux avoir en même
temps alain juppé laurence parisot et
des syndicalistes de sud ou
d'alternatiba ce n'était pas évident
c'est dire que le climat est il ya que
le climat je pense qu'il peut on et d'un
pays très morcelé où les gens sont
inquiets pour leur avenir au lieu de
s'engueuler sur chaque sujet on pourrait
se rassembler avec un vrai plan d'action
pour le climat et la biodiversité
mais ça suppose qu'on ait des
financements et du coup si on a des
vrais financement ça peut être une bonne
nouvelle parce que beaucoup de
politiques nous disent oui bien sur le
climat mais vous comprenez il ya une
demande de justice sociale il faut qu'on
choisisse ben angus non qu'il faut pas
choisir agir pour le climat est une
façon d'améliorer le fait du progrès
social un jour j'étais je voyais à
monsieur qui vivait sens que tu dises
vers 6hoo ancienne danseuse assuré
social c'est très intéressant et valérie
a dit un truc aussi très intéressant sur
les tic
pour moi j'ai dû casser la feb a dit
vas-y je peux casser un peu la phase est
d'accord donc la justice sociale
coopération entre les nations
l'entrée de la fraternité ça ça marche
quand on mange facilement de choses très
concrètes pendant j'étais à mulhouse
voiture avec une dame qui vit avec le
rsa et qui m'a expliqué comment chaque
fois que quelqu'un sonne chez elle elle
a peur de se faire [__] dehors
isabelle c'est comme ça je ne peux
chouette je n'ai jamais pensé qu'il
fallait choisir entre le climat la
biodiversité et la justice sociale en
sont arrivés à ce qu'ils veulent ce
circuit mais non mais pas identifié les
deux sujets parlons franchement ça fait
30 ans voilà ça fait 30 ans que shanghai
et sur les questions sociales le niveau
du débat sur les questions économiques
et sociales est aussi pauvre quand
antoine riboud en 93 antoine lui patron
dan hollande il faut passer à 4 jours
sans étape intermédiaire c'était quand
même un des plus grands patrons d'europe
en 95 jacques chirac va chez brioche
pasquier ni dans ce qui se fait chez
brioche pasquier la semaine de quatre
jours pourquoi ça se fait pas ailleurs
en 95 à la une des journaux il ya le
rapport boissonnat qui dit qu'il faut
baisser de 20% le travail est encore
aujourd'hui le président de la
république nous dit qu'il faut
travailler plus c'est atterrant le
niveau qu'on va les gains de
productivité personne ne peut croire
qu'il faut travailler plus est la
meilleure façon de sauver les retraites
la meilleure façon de sauver des
retraites j'aimerais que j'espère que
bruno le maire nous regarde au lieu de
baisser les retraites c'est d'avoir un
vrai plan pour le climat mettre le
paquet sur l'isolation des bâtiments et
les transports en commun on peut créer
900 mille emplois en france 900 milles
et relancer la négociation sur les
quatre jours tu sais que chez brioche
pasquier chez mamie nova chez fleury
michon il ya des centaines et demi de
salariés qui sont passés à quatre jours
sans baisser les salaires parce que
l'entreprise si elle passe à 4 jours est
là et qu'elle crée des emplois au moins
10% emplois derrière de payer les
cotisations chômage et si on a toutes
les entreprises en france qui ont
quelques années passent à quatre jours
avec les financements qu'on propose on
peut créer un million six cent mille
emplois donc un vrai plan climat la dame
dit qu'on peut créer 900 milles en place
sur tout le territoire neuf cent mille
emplois le climat est un million six
cent mille emplois et de la semaine de
quatre jours tu crées au total deux
millions cinq cent mille emplois deux
millions cinq cent mille emplois vrais
de vrais emplois et ça fait 2 millions
500 mille personnes qui ne sont plus au
chômage et qui vont cotiser pour les
caisses de retraite donc elles de façon
radicalement différente arriver à
l'équilibré retraite soit tu diminues
les retraits de tout le monde et
retraite pour une réforme courageuse
comme dit bruno le maire soit tu crées
deux millions et demi d'emplois étape
plutôt un excédent de la déraillement
trader je reviens sur la justice sociale
par dont j'aimerais quand même placé cet
exemple le dernier qui me fait le coup
je lèche dans la cave
j'ai trente secondes sks calmer parce
que ça m'énerve vraiment y compris au
parlement européen des gens qu'ils
m'expliquent bien sur le climat mais
d'abord la justice sociale est en fait
une font souvent ni l'un ni l'autre je
prends cet exemple de ce monsieur qui
vit dans un hlm qui depuis quinze ans
était d'un hlm et qui me dit depuis
trois ans ça y est on a isolé nôtre
celle m eh bien on a moins chaud l'été
on a moins froid l'hiver et je gagne
c'est lui qui parle je gagne 800 euros
chaque année pour mes dépenses de
chauffage voilà donc ça crée de l'emploi
c'est bon pour la planète ce monsieur
dit que c'est confortable et qui gagne
pour sa famille 800 euros et la question
est de savoir comment le finance parce
que le maire de la commune me dit mais
j'espère qu'il va gagner la bataille au
niveau européen parce qu'on peut faire
des trucs qui sont géniaux maintenant
fait trois ou quatre chaque année alors
qu'on voudrait en faire 30 et donc si on
arrive à créer la taxe mais je le répète
je le répète il ya une primaire
populaire et qu'on arrive à se
rassembler au lieu de jouer chacun dans
son coin de façon suicidaire et qu'on
gagne le pouvoir je continue à penser
qu'on peut gagner le pouvoir en avril
prochain on fait un sommet européen
extraordinaire au mois de mai ce sera la
présidence française et en mai on aura
débloquer la négociation sur la taxe sur
la spéculation sur un impôt sur les
milliardaires et un an plus tard
l'argent arrive le secteur du bâtiment
aura le temps de former des gens si on
sait qu'il ya de l'argent qui arrive
pendant 20 ans le secteur du bâtiment
pourra recruter des gens mathon
politique ce matin mais c'est une fois
dire qu'elle l'espoir il ya plein de
gens qui se dit c'est foutu
excellent je vous pose une question à
tous les deux croissance ou décroissance
valérie
en fait sur la partie sur la partie
climat les évaluations qu'on fait nous
elles sont vraiment à vocation mondiale
et quand organe au niveau mondial il ya
une immense partie des gens qui ne vit
pas dignement qui a pas un accès minimum
à l'énergie qui dispose pas des
infrastructures de santé donc il ya un
besoin de croissance pour que chacun
puisse vivre dignement et pour moi la
question de fond c'est pas la question
de la croissance en tant que tel c'est
la question de la redistribution des
richesses produites la question de la
redistribution pour réduire l'extrême
pauvreté c'est d'ailleurs en fait une
question qu'on nous avait posé quand on
a fait le rapport du giec qui portait
sur un degré et demi qui était le
suivant qu'est ce qu'on gagne si on
limite le réchauffement à un niveau très
bas qu'est ce qu'on gagne par rapport à
des impacts éviter on comprend bien que
l'investissement l'effort sur la baisse
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est brutal dans ce cas là c'est
vraiment une baisse et des changements
très rapides dans tous les secteurs
d'activité et qu'est ce qu'on gagne en
termes de soutenabilité premiers
objectifs d'un développement soutenable
c'est éliminer l'extrême pauvreté c'est
agir pour contre l'insécurité
alimentaire
ces données d'accès à l'eau à tout le
monde c'est préserver la biodiversité
marine qui te tient à coeur et
terrestres voilà et donc quand on
regarde un changement climatique non
maîtrisée ça fout tout en l'air c'est
clair surtout ce qu'on appelle
soutenabilité cesser les choses
actuellement critiques sont exacerbées
si on agit de manière intelligente en
pour réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre pour protéger les plus
vulnérables et les plus pauvres en fait
on peut construire un développement
soutenable vraiment soutenable et ça
c'est pas une question de france ou
décroissance est pointée stage me sens
forte croissance et comment mesure
l'efficacité des politiques publiques et
c'est pas seulement le pib voilà et en
france on a un certain nombre
d'objectifs sur le développement
soutenable
qui en entend parler est-ce qu'on en
prend un s contient vraiment content
avec l'académie de la 2d technologie des
sciences et de l'agriculture on a passé
en revue par exemple les effets de la
pandémie sur cela on a passé en revue
les réponses la pandémie sur cela et ce
qu'on entre en fait c'est que ce n'était
pas assez pris en compte c'est évident
la pandémie est l'autre manière très
claire qui était le plus directement
affectées par les travailleurs
saisonniers des poufs les travailleurs
saisonniers leur secteur agricole du
livre hubert voilà les gens qui sont les
plus précaires compas puce protégé qui
étaient en première ligne on l'a vu de
manière évidente et de l'autre côté au
niveau mondial si on n'arrive pas à
donner l'accès aux vaccins en
particulier dans toutes les régions du
monde on s'en sortira pas non plus donc
la pandémie le montrons et la question
du changement climatique elle le montre
aussi en première ligne c'est pas pour
moi une question de croissance ou
décroissance c'est une question de
comment permettre à chacun de vivre
dignement sachant qu'aujourd'hui en
france il ya un facteur 4 en gros un des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre entre
les 10% les plus démunis et les 10% les
plus aisés donc c'est évident que la
question de l'effort du juste partage de
l'effort c'est quelque chose de
fondamental moi je suis physicienne
c'est pas moi qui peut apporter des
réponses précises à la manière de faire
mais les économistes par exemple quand
il analyse la possibilité d'agir s'ils
prennent pas en compte les effets de
redistribution ils vont se planter ils
vont se planter comme on l'a vu avec la
fiscalité sur les carburants ça peut pas
marcher donc cette question en fait des
inégalités de ce qui est juste perçue
comme juste c'est quelque chose qui va
être critique en fait dans la manière
d'aborder les questions climat de plus
en plus et moi je termine juste en
disant moi j'ai un sentiment d'urgence
entre temps j'ai un sentiment d'urgence
parce qu'en fait on court derrière le
changement climatique il est là il
s'accentue il est comme on l'avait
anticipé depuis longtemps en fait en
sciences du climat mais il est là les
pertes et les dommages ses croissants et
donc ça va prendre aussi des capacités
d'action une partie de plus en plus
grande donc plainte pour retard de
l'action
puis on sera le dos au mur et plus ce
sera compliqué d'agir aussi sur la cause
du problème serre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et actions ses soeurs du
rêve
donc mais une population au mouvement il
faut les faire rêver ou les mettre
derrière un dictateur oui donc étant dit
je suis pas d'accord en fait ouais mais
je suis très content mais oui ça sent la
pelure en discuter donc l'action sur du
rêve
qu'est-ce qui fait rêver en ce moment
c'est de ne pas crever ou de vivre d'une
façon différente et donc je rebondis sur
un commentaire d'internet que font-ils
pour garder le moral car personnellement
toutes ces mauvaises nouvelles me
déprime quel guide pour faire les bons
gestes au quotidien
alors de ce point de vue là quand vous
faites pour l'urd et morale quand on
voit les des politiques stupide quand on
voit direction tout le temps qu'il n'y a
pas de rêve que tu la marge de manoeuvre
est aussi grande qu'un trou de souris il
faut que je précise que depuis trois ans
je suis à fond de moi dans le fait de
faire cet état des lieux scientifique
j'ai travaillé avec 234 chercheurs
brillante de 65 ans ou drosson dams
houssin non non je veux juste dire ça je
les ils ont passé en revue 14000
publications scientifiques il ya eu
plusieurs phases de relecture on a reçu
plus de 78 le commentaire c'est vraiment
une oeuvre collective en fait un avec le
le regard critique qui est essentiel
parce que c'est ce qui permet d'être
rigoureux exhaustif transparent donc moi
j'étais dans cette dynamique là en fait
pandémie on passe en virtuel on nous dit
que c'est pas possible on y arrive des
choses qui était perçu comme un possible
par exemple ne serait ce que pour le
giec faire nos réunions virtuellement on
l'a fait l'approbation de notre rapport
195 pays leurs représentants des
centaines de personnes on regarde ligne
par ligne mot par mot figure par figurer
en fait ce qui en sort c'est encore plus
fort que ce que l'on avait rédigé au
départ parce qu on a rajouté des
éléments deux semaines en virtuel nous
avait dit que c'était pas possible on
l'a fait voilà
par exemple les gens plus expérimentés
qui pensaient que pour pouvoir
s'accorder sur quelque chose on avait
besoin de voyager d'un continent à
l'autre et d'être dans la même pièce et
vieux parce que c'était leur habitude
voilà il se fait vieux c'était leurs
habitudes et donc la question c'est
quand on a un choc on peut faire
autrement on peut se réinventer on peut
faire les choses on peut les faire
ensemble autrement et intelligemment ça
prend plus de temps faut beaucoup se
coordonner faut bien planifier mais ça
peut être fait donc qu'est-ce qui me
donne de l'énergie pas l'optimisme de
l'énergie c'est cette intelligence
collective avec laquelle j'étais en
prise tout le temps c'est le fait
d'arriver à surmonter pas mal
d'obstacles ensemble c'est quand on met
en place des pratiques qui sont
inclusive qui font que chacun se sont
légitimes quel que soit son expérience
son genre sa langue natale qu'ils
puissent exprimer participer en fait on
voit vraiment un résultat qui est bien
meilleur voilà donc moi c'est ça qui m'a
porté pendant trois ans après est ce que
je suis optimiste mans je suis
particulièrement lucide sur l'ampleur
des enjeux je les voit très clairement
partout dans le monde mais je suis aussi
responsable dans ma vie personnelle je
mesure mon empreinte carbone j'agis
c'est pas toujours évident il ya parfois
des choix qui sont difficiles à faire
des priorités des choses comme ça
c'était quoi leur dis bah en fait bon
aller les choix récents sais je suis
devenue végétarienne ya quelques années
parce que sur mon alimentation je
n'arrivais pas à agir autrement ben
voilà c'est pas compliqué c'est pas
forcément compris c'est pas forcément
évident dans une vie de famille et puis
ces voix là on a une vieille voiture qui
a 12 ans doit la changer qu'est-ce qu'on
prend on a parfois des grandes distances
c'est pas toujours facile et puis j'ai
réussi à voir les chiffres sur un
véhicule hybride rechargeable
l'empreinte à la production j'ai calculé
avec la manière dont on se déplace avec
ma famille et on a réussi avec ce
véhicule à la place d'un vieux à réduire
en fait d'à peu près 30% à 40% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
associées à notre ancienne d'un problème
à l'épaule de constats d'huissier et le
surcoût de la petite batterie ça a été
effacée en ciment kg ses 1 120 kg non
c'est 700 kg de co2 de la batterie pour
un véhicule rechargeable 50 km un peu
profité d'un constructeur intel commune
qui louent 700 kg de co2 c'est le
chiffre que m'a donnée le constructeur
pour la batterie de corps de co2 en tout
cas c'est le chiffre que j'ai eu et qui
est cohérent avec les chiffres que
j'avais obtenu par ailleurs voilà donc
ces quelques exemples mais donc quand on
veut agir de manière effective bien sûr
il faut mesurer les gaz à effet de serre
c'est invisible ça se voit pas quand on
achète un produit on sait pas ce que ça
fait donc il ya quelques outils l'ademe
met à la disposition des petits
calculateur qu'on peut utiliser dans sa
vie de famille il ya des méthodes pour
faire des bilans carbone dans le cadre
professionnel on peut le faire à
l'échelle d'une ville quand on gère des
finances ans on peut avoir des outils de
gestion verte en fait de la fiscalité
des investissements
on peut analyser le plan de relance de
la france à l'angle de ce qui est
positif ou négatif pour le climat on
peut le faire sur l'ensemble des
dépenses budgétaires en fait d'une année
donnée et quand on a cette grille
d'analysé sa guide la décision bien sûr
sinon on est aveugle on peut avoir
beaucoup de bonne volonté mais être
aveugle juste une question jours
très intéressant le gic
logique
je suis en train de traduire la question
en même temps en france est ce qu'elle
n'arrive en anglais posée en anglais
ici si pie xi si oui liste interactive
atlas showcasing tatoué humanity can't
take with global warming
rising from one point 5 points pour neuf
five to freely gries
qu'elle quel chemin on est à l'heure
actuelle est-ce que ce qu'est ce que ça
veut dire quatre tours et en plus c'est
à quoi ça ressemble alors donc l'atlas
interactif c'est un chouette outil parce
que ça permet à quelqu'un qui a envie
d'en savoir plus de d'utiliser les
informations scientifiques que nous on a
évalué donc les projections en
particulier d'évolution future du climat
sur des moyennes des indicateurs
d'impact particulier papa les
conséquences 1 il caractéristiques
physiques région par région en fonction
du niveau de réchauffement en fonction
de l'horizon temporel les prochains 20
ans milieu du siècle fin de siècle ou en
fonction du scénario d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre donc ça permet de
récupérer les données ça permet de les
visualiser de les manipuler et je pense
que ta communauté elle peut être
particulièrement intéressé nous on a
besoin de relais on a besoin de gens qui
s'approprient ces éléments et puis qui
approfondissent les analyses et la
communauté française en sciences du
climat ils demandent pas mieux en fait
que de travailler davantage justement
sur le partage des informations en a
besoin de beaucoup plus de gens par
rapport à ces données on a vu les trucs
géniaux qui ont été faits pour la
pandémie moi je rêve de choses
similaires pour le climat qui permette à
chacun finalement de s'approprier ces
choses là et donc où on en est ben on en
est avec des émissions mondiales qui ont
augmenté une baisse transitoire éphémère
de la pandémie qu'est ce que ça va faire
les plans de relance d'où le rebond
économique est-ce que ça va verrouiller
des trajectoires fortement et missive
est ce qu'on va défendre mordicus les
secteurs les plus pollueurs ce qui émet
le plus de gaz à effet de serre canton
de produits quand on utilise est ce qu à
l inverse on va favoriser les choses
transformative qui vont permettre en
fait d'avoir des entreprises qui vont
rester dans la durée des emplois qu'on
va pas délocaliser c'est une question
qui reste ouverte sur les promesses qui
avaient été faites en 2015 elles sont
pas à la hauteur en fait si on veut
vraiment réussir à limiter le
réchauffement largement en dessous de
deux degrés où près de un degré et demi
il faut que les émissions elle commence
à diminuer maintenant pour aller vers
nette zéro pour le co2 en 2050 ou 2060
disent en gros c'est ça la marge de
manoeuvre et les promesses qui avaient
été faites elles impliquent que les
émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre confondues au lieu de continuer à
augmenter elles stagnent jusqu'en 2030
la baisse n'est pas encore engagée mais
on peut le faire on peut le faire en
agissant plus vite les solutions elles
sont là elles existent dans tous les
secteurs le bâtiment l'agriculture
l'industrie les transports ça existe en
fait est ce que les organismes je te
donne un ton juste un regard est ce que
les les organismes de propagande aux
fiches officiel vous ont contacté genre
les chrétiens les musulmans les juifs
les bouddhistes est-ce qui vous ont
contacté pour en discuter
j'ai du mal à comprendre en fait le
modèle est exact de la question à
égalité ça fait 2000 on que l'église
chrétienne romaine sont les maîtres de
la propagande si j'avais sévérité si on
peut faire passer à leurs joies et qu'il
faut moins manger de viande ce serait
bien non alors sur ce côté là j'ai
parfois des invitations doit intervenir
dans des cadres par exemple de nico de
mouvements chrétiens alors moi pas le
vatican mais j'étais intervenu avec
l'académie pontificale en fait un qui
est basé au vatican lors de la
conférence sur le climat en pologne je
suis souvent sollicité par exemple par
des mouvements d'églises protestantes
aussi plutôt en france angers des
collègues dans d'autres pays qui
travaillent sur le climat qui ont été
sollicités par des mouvements religieux
musulmans par exemple au proche orient
au maghreb qui prennent très au sérieux
cette question là voilà donc moi
personnellement je n'ai pas de religion
c'est quelque chose qui est extérieur à
maintenant tu prônes science est
usuellement propre rapport au monde vous
n'avez pas d'amis imaginaire mais par
contre mais par contre ce que je
comprends c'est qu'il ya une dimension
éthique il ya une dimension morale et
finalement ce qui me frappe c'est que
quelles que soient les convictions
personnelles qu'on peut avoir sur des
questions de vers quoi on veut aller
ensemble ce qu'on veut préserver ce
qu'on veut transmettre qu'on le voit
comme le fruit d'une création qu'on le
voit comme le fruit du hasard et de
l'évolution il ya des choses qui nous
rassemblent beaucoup plus que de choses
qui peuvent nous diviser parfois pire
on a été reçu par le pape je pense que
répondre à la question sur la croissance
non mais c'était assez émouvant parce
qu'on a été reçu avec camille etienne
avec cyril dion et le pape ne dit qu'il
fallait faire la révolution le pape a
dit mais il faut tout changer que après
2008 ans après la crise de 2008 on avait
dit qu'on allait tout changer on n'a
rien changé et le pape c'est étonnant sa
liberté de parole en expliquant qu'un
système économique où l'argent domine
tout où l'argent devient une idole ou
l'argent fournir la cohésion sociale
fournie avec le climat la biodiversité
il dit pas que c'est de la merde comme
le dit rien adolescents douala mais le
pas petit c'est le fumier du diable un
système économique où l'argent suit pour
ça ils sont bien le souligner williams à
ce danger là ces qualifs dis bien mais
ça 10 et voilà et en quand elle a quitté
inzaghi mais il faut faire la révolution
il faut effectivement tout changer voilà
donc je pense qu'il a eu sa fiche s il a
ainsi affiché sous un ballon c'est son
ip son ip aux autorités mais parce que
je n'en mets si je parle du pabx et si
tu peux la question c'est que
effectivement né sur une question
spirituelle qu'on soit croyant ou pas
croyant c est ce que l'humanité va vers
son suicide en le sachant on nous a dit
à l'école qu'on était des homo sapiens
sapiens la branche la plus évoluée des
primates mais parfois demandes sont nés
des sapiens sapiens ou des débits lui ce
débile us parce qu'on sait qu'on va vers
un suicide et c'est pas dans trois
siècles on espère tous être encore dans
vivant dans 20 ans et dans 20 ans vivra
des scènes d'horreur le problème de
l'accès à l'eau moi je pense et aucun
climatologue ne m'a dit que je
m'inquiétais pour rien je pense qu'il y
aura des scènes d'horreur des scènes de
violence absolue dans vingt ans et on se
dira mais [__] on nous l'avait dit je
sais pas une tendance n'est pas une
surprise pendant deux ans mais non je
suis désolé numérique des coups de bâton
je suis vraiment un non violent c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait mais ils ont du
sang sur les mains ils ont du sang sur
les mains quand ils ne font rien pour
contrer le chômage se rappelle que le
chômage tu quinze mille personnes chaque
année l'inserm dit que le chômage fait
quinze mille morts en france et le
dérèglement climatique dont on a parlé
des travaux du giec mais l'om aime bien
sortir une étude qui dit que le nombre
d'événements climatiques extrêmes a été
multiplié par cinq en 50 ans il ya des
centaines de morts tous les mois voilà
et on verra internet est-ce que la
bienséance et le ronron de ne jamais
s'énerver nous empêche de taper du poing
sur la table pour exiger des changements
des oligarques je me suis tapé sur le
front est tu m'as repris donc voila moi
je pense effectivement qui n'ont aucune
excuse
que la violence n'est pas la solution
aller qu'à la castagne mais qu'il faut
sans doute qu'on utilise encore des
actions non violentes et surtout qu'on
profite la question non violente la plus
efficace ce sont les élections on est un
pays démocratique il ya une équipe qui
aura eu tous les pouvoirs pendant cinq
ans et qui manifestement je ne dis pas
que c'est facile je dis pas qu'il ya une
baguette magique mais quand il ya 150
citoyens qui ont travaillé par la
convention citoyenne qui a travaillé
pendant un an et demi qui débouche sur
149 propositions très concrètes emmanuel
macron dis bravo il y en a 3 je sors mon
joker miliana 146 qu'ils ont vraiment
très bonne chose et je vous promets je
reprends les 146 propositions et qu'à la
fin tout le monde dit qu'il a repris
même pas 5% et le conseil d'état et le
conseil points qui disent non on n'est
pas du tout à la hauteur eh ben ça veut
dire que ces gens là ont du sang sur les
mains ça sert à rien qui passe d'un
sommet extraordinaire pour dire que qui
vont sauver la planète ou la
biodiversité sur la question de la
croissance qui avait posé la question
d'abord je veux dire que j'étais
d'accord à 100% avec ce qu'a dit valérie
et g bravo d'avoir commencé par les pays
du sud parce que moi j'aurais commencé
comme un gros bourrin parler répondre
pour des pays européens je trouve que
c'est important de dire que dans les
pays du sud il ya un besoin
effectivement de vivre mieux donc
d'avoir un niveau de vie qui augmente ce
qui ne veut pas dire une consommation de
pétrole et de gaz plus importante c'est
aussi pour ça que nous on veut un plan
d'investissement massif un nouveau
partenariat avec l'afrique mettre de
l'argent et puis une nouvelle
gouvernance parce que beaucoup
d'africains veulent avoir un niveau de
vie qui augmente ça se comprend mais
finissent de pétrole il veut la
répulsion d'amour il veut juste un petit
survie à ça il ya ça et puis aussi le
fait d'avoir un niveau de vie plus
important ça dépend dans quelle zone
d'afrique tuer mais on peut avoir un
niveau de vie plus important sans brûler
plus de charbon et de pétrole en afrique
comme ailleurs en afrique comme ailleurs
on peut faire un travail de sobriété on
peut avoir d'autres modes de cuisson de
demande alimentaire on peut avoir des la
biomasse il ya tout ce qu'il faut comme
ressource en le soleil la forêt a eu
l'intelligence de l'afrique à toutes les
ressources prod ne pas passer par la
case pétrole et gaz comme comme l'europe
mais avoir un niveau de vie et un niveau
de consommation d'énergie qui progresse
sans faire voilà je voudrais quand même
sur la question de la croissance dire
que dans nos pays je n'en peux plus de
voir tous les dirigeants et je donnerai
pas de nombre pour pas vexer bruno le
maire mais que à chaque fois qu'on nous
explique que ça y est la croissance
revient mais je sais pas s'il faut en
rire ou en pleurer d'ailleurs le
collectif roosevelt avait fait une vidéo
très drôle on voyait raymond barre qui
voulait ça y est la croissance revient
pierre mauroy la voilà voilà la courbe
de là en france depuis 50 ans je suis
désolé pour ceux qui me suivent depuis
25 ans je l'accueille lyssois la
révolution de la croissance en france
depuis 50 ans décennie par décennie on
était à 5,6 voilà il faut être très
optimiste pour porter que la croissance
revient mais vous allez me dire gros
porteur vous allez me dire vous allez me
dire oui mais c'est pas en france l'état
est obèse ya pas de politique
industrielle regardez l'allemagne donc
pour la première fois sur singer view
c'est là une nouvelle l'évolution de la
croissance en allemagne depuis 50 ans
voilà la locomotive allemande
la locomotive allemande voilà et comme
rapporteur général du budget avant que
le virus ne fera pas les deux fois par
mois à berlin et je me rappelle que la
dernière conférence de presse du patron
de la bundesbank jens weidmann juste
avant noël il ya presque deux ans il est
l'allemagne en train de retomber en
récession donc je rappelle pour bruno le
maire et autres ou pour arnaud
montebourg qui nous dit qu'il suffirait
d'avoir une politique industrielle il a
raison il faut une politique
industrielle il faut on s'est rendu
compte que les masques viennent de chine
que des molécules importantes viennent
de chine donc oui il faut réfléchir à
une vraie politique industrielle pour
notre pays mais de là à dire que ça va
suffire pour le plein emploi en
allemagne à 6 millions de petits boulots
6 millions salariés qui ont 450 euros
par mois mais donc voilà l'évolution de
la loco la croissance en allemagne les
derniers points qui va énerver un peu la
légende du front national comment
l'allemagne éviter la récession depuis
dix ans c'est juste parce qu'elle a
cueilli un million et demi de réfugiés
syriens c'est les chiffres officiels si
l'allemagne n'avait pas accueilli un
million et demi de réfugiés syriens elle
avait une croissance à 0,4 0,4 et voilà
et n'importe quand les états unis
peuvent s'effondrer je le rappelle avant
que le virus n'arrive paradoxalement le
virus a permis de mettre des milliers de
milliards pour faire un plan de relance
mais voilà la courbe tu m'avais invités
ya trois ans j'avais montré ça c'est la
dette aux tables états unis on voit que
c'est totalement flippant et il ya trois
ans à la une des échos qui n'est pas un
journal conspirationnistes le fmi qui
dit attention le fmi nous crêpes
préparées par ne s'inquiète d'une
nouvelle crise mondiale la phrase repris
en gros d'après le fmi la prochaine
crise peut être dix fois plus grave que
2008 d'après le fmi la prochaine crise
peut être plus dix fois plus grave que
2008 est paradoxalement avec le virus il
ya eu des centaines ou milliers de morts
c'était l'horreur du confinement voilà
mais du point de vue économique on a mis
tellement de milliers de milliards pour
faire un plan de relance qu'on a
prolongé le système économique mais que
l'on peu n'importe quand à voir la crise
économique est attendue donc miser sur
la croissance c'est se moquer du monde
on ne peut plus la croissance ne veut
plus rien dire des en 1970 le livre que
jacques qui fait que jacques delors
émerger dans le débat public en 1970 si
jacques delors est devenu connu c'est
parce qu'il a fait un livre sur les
indicateurs sociaux visés le pib ne veut
rien dire le pib ne veut rien dire il
faut des indicateurs sociaux et
maintenant ils diraient de développement
durable et donc miser sur la croissance
pour financer les retraites ou pour
l'emploi c'est juste une grosse blague
la meilleure façon de créer des emplois
et de financer les retraites c'est
d'avoir un vrai plan d'investissement
pour le climat y compris des
financements européens
mettre une taxe sur la spéculation une
taxe les milliardaires utiliser
autrement l'argent de la banque centrale
neuf cent mille emplois avec un vrai
plan climat et relancer la négociation
sur la semaine de quatre jours on donne
la parole aux patrons et aux salariés de
mamie nova aux patrons et salariés de
faé michon et avec ça on crée deux
millions et demi d'emplois chez hydro si
on peut vivre mieux cependant est ce que
le but est de vivre mieux le but est
d'éviter le chaos moi j'étais un ami de
stéphane hessel j'ai eu la chance de
vivre existe des grands et il était dans
la résistance ils ont fait le conseil
national de la résistance il avait un
double objectif c'était but et des nazis
libéré le pays et leur programme c'était
magnifique les jours heureux leur
programme c'était mettre en place une
sécurité sociale améliorer le
fonctionnement des médias sur du ruf
donc en même temps éviter le chaos à
l'époque c'était lutter contre les nazis
et il était risqué des risques et la
mort ainsi se faisait chauffer c'était
une balle à et en même temps il avait eu
le courage d'inventer un autre modèle
pour vivre heureux et je pense que nous
notre avis surtout ils ont dit surtout
des réserves de pétrole mais pendant ce
que je veux dire c'est que l'objectif
est double aujourd'hui le monde a changé
mais l'objectif est double c'est éviter
le chaos c'est pas les nazis c'est le
dérèglement climatique et l'effondrement
d'aig diversité qui peut nous n le chaos
et vivre mieux si vous allez sur le site
les jours heureux 2022 les jours heureux
vous trouver quelques propositions
aurélie ça parler de la question de vers
quel futur on se projette qu'est ce que
c'est un futur qu'on veut pas la
dystopie et qu'est ce que c'est un futur
souhaitable et ça pour ça en fait il ya
besoin d'autres personnes que nous des
physiciens du climat et a besoin
d'autres personnes qui finalement
récupère nos informations et puis celles
qui vont venir sur les impacts
supplémentaires ou éviter et puis
l'ensemble des solutions qui permettent
de permettre à chacun de vivre mantoue
de vivre décemment tout en réduisant les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et à
partir de là en fait on peut créer ses
visions du monde ces récits les partager
ça peut créer un effet d'entraînement
dans le rapport du giec sur 1° nuit on a
des c ça dans un des encadrés à la fin
du rapport on a décrit trois futurs
possibles un futur où on agit maintenant
on réoriente les investissements c'est
pas délirant en fait c'est beaucoup
moins coûteux que ce qui a été fait pour
la pandémie on transforme vraiment de
manière importante un certain nombre de
secteurs d'activité et puis on vit avec
un climat qui change de manière minimale
et on aide ceux qui sont les plus
exposés à surmonter les difficultés
et puis il ya d'autres évolutions
futures possibles et puis ça ça peut se
décliner ça peut se décliner à l'échelle
d'une ville à l'échelle d'un pays mais
il ya besoin d'autre chose que
simplement le travail de physiciens du
climat ta communauté en fait elle peut
aider à ça je pense que c'est important
et tue tous les jours et tu précédente
éclipse tu poses et aussi la question de
est-ce qu'il faut taper du poing sur la
table moi je moi personnellement c'est
pas ma façon de voir les choses sur la
table d'un an mais c'est pas ma
personnalité c'est pas ma façon de faire
je suis très consciente du fait que
quand on fait ce rappel à la réalité
c'est-à-dire là où on en est là où on
peut aller sur le temps qu'on a perdu
finalement la réalité des conséquences
sévères d'un changement climatique dû à
l'influencé humaine qui est déjà là je
sais que c'est lourd j'essaie de le
partager de manière la plus
bienveillante possible j'essaie de le
partager de sorte à ce que les gens
n'intègre et que chacun à son échelle
trice contribué à partager les
connaissances et à agir et voilà et ce
pointage pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'important c'est le côté le discours
apocalypse effondrement etc je suis pas
sûr que ce soit un discours qui aident à
agir à l'échelle nécessaires
collectivement je suis particulièrement
attaché à la vie démocratique c'est une
chance en fait moi je suis une femme les
femmes elles votent pas depuis tellement
longtemps aussi voilà tout ça c'est pour
que tu veux être ton kate tu sais
beaucoup tu votes je vote jamais moi
personnellement et pour payer des taxes
non mais personnellement je n'ai jamais
voté pop et tu piges brise je n'ai
jamais voté par adhésion j'ai toujours
voté par minimes à nîmes
optimisation sous contrainte on va dire
personnellement très bien dit voilà mais
ce dont j'ai besoin pour pouvoir voter
c'est d'avoir des programmes clairs sur
des questions qui nous tiennent à coeur
et les questions qui me tiennent à coeur
c'est sur les enjeux climat sur les
enjeux biodiversité et sur la question
de mettre en place des transitions qui
soit juste qu'est ce qui est proposé
dans les années à venir pour moi
personnellement comme citoyenne avoir
une information précise là dessus c'est
chose qui est critique et souvent je ne
trouve pas donc c'est pour ça que
j'insiste sur les engagements qui sont
pris tu l'as dit clairement une fois que
quelqu'un est élu reid a plus le temps
il a plus le temps passe que il est il
gère les affaires courantes les crises
les trucs voilà donc ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir au minimum un
plan d'action précédemment quoi de
respecter sa parole non il n'a plus le
temps de réfléchir à ce qu'il veut faire
il est dans l'axé avant ça non
alors on parle d'anticipation après on
parle d' anticipe désole pierre on parle
d'anticipation parle de tout ça il ya
plus d'une dizaine d'années j'avais été
fou que le bord des larmes et du temps
où ça s'appelait collège interarmées de
défense mais vous comprenez avec
l'époque qu'on est en train de traverser
c'est devenu école de guerre
donc à l'époque c'était les
répercussions du réchauffement
climatique sur le livre blanc de la
défense française et
je m'étais pris menée avec
général et je lui avais dit
un truc qui lui est resté bien dans les
dents parce que c'est quelque chose qui
est bien connu chez les militaires je
lui ai dit vous n'avez pas anticipé vous
vous êtes fait surprendre dont vous avez
perdu
donc tous les militaires connaissent
cette phrase là la question je te pose
ses îles tu as déjà répandue les
militaires il consulte un peu parce que
c'est eux un peu les femmes de ménage de
du réchauffement climatique parce que
qu'est-ce qui va être obligé de gérer
les milliers de migrants qui vont
débarquer parce qu'ils ont plus rien à
bouffer ils se sont cramés ils ont
solecki leur tape sur la tête ils se
font rares et j'ai parlé sauterelles qui
stoppe la malaria il se tape les amibes
dans la flotte et j'en passe et des
meilleurs c'est les militaires qui vont
gérer ça rien d'autres dîners de la tête
c'est les militaires qui vont gérer en
fait je domine de la tête parce que dans
beaucoup de régions du monde le fait de
se déplacer régulièrement en interne
c'est une stratégie intelligente ans
pour assurer des revenus pour sa famille
voilà et le fasse et en interne là tu
parles des flux migratoires qui ne se
passe que en afrique non à l'intérieur
de son propre pays d'accueil est d'une
zone par exemple rural vers une zone
urbaine pour compléter la france
mauvaise récolte etc ça fait partie en
fait des choses qui existent couramment
ses déplacements là et ce dont tu parles
c'est des déplacements qui sont souvent
pilotés par l'absence de perspectives
économiques en fait mais aussi par la
manière dont notre mode de vie et
véhiculer partout et puis un site tout
un chacun
apporte un plat spears autant d'énergie
que nous d'une autre manière voilà et
donc effectivement moi je vois une prise
de conscience croissante des enjeux en
fait plus largement de sécurité pas
simplement pour les militaires mais des
enjeux de sécurité qui sont croisés que
les enjeux climat s'écoeurer entre en
eau sécurité alimentaire sécurité par
rapport aux risques de conflit ou de
tension pas uniquement les déplacements
de population les gens qui partent à
grande échelle c'est quand on a un
gouvernement totalement incompétents et
puis un truc qui s'effondrent comme en
syrie ou ou l'absence de gouvernement
dans d'autres régions du monde que
l'hôpital en france quoi donc c'est
autre chose là c'est aussi des enjeux en
fait à l'intérieur de chaque pays de dun
cadre collectif voilà donc quand ça
manque c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour
tous
je voulais revenir aussi sur un point
est à mentionner tout à l'heure parce
que il me tient à coeur on sort d'une
pandémie qui a posé beaucoup de
questions des passants tir est toujours
sur les enjeux croisés il ya des enjeux
très importants croisé santé climat est
ce qu'on voit que ce soit pour la
pollution de l'air que ce soit pour
l'alimentation on travaille toujours en
silo et il ya un manque d'articulation
entre la vision qu'on a de ce qui permet
de réduire des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre qui est parfois vu comme un
fardeau alors qu'en fait on peut le voir
comme une opportunité pour aussi
améliorée de manière spectaculaire la
qualité de l'air à condition de le faire
bien donc c'est une chose qu'on a abordé
dans notre rapport les enjeux croisés
climat et qualité de l'air d'une manière
beaucoup plus fine qu'avant et quand on
regarde en termes de santé publique dans
le monde les conséquences de la mauvaise
qualité de l'air ils sont colossaux en
fait les coûts suite ou 58 morte en
hausse est en fait une durée de vie qui
se raccourcissent et des maladies
chroniques qui touche les enfants qui
touche les adultes en particulier autour
des grandes villes très pollué et puis
dans les régions qui sont très pollué
parce que l'industrie est très concentré
avec des normes plus strictes voilà et
donc là il ya des enjeux qui sont
extrêmement importants et ce qu'on
montre souvent quand on parle de clans
met l'accent sur les émissions de
dioxyde de carbone le fait de brûler
moins de charbon de pétrole moines gaz
quand on brûle ça on m'a aussi des
particules qui refroidissent qui masque
une partie du réchauffement est ce qu'on
entre dans notre rapport c'est que un
des facteurs qui augmentent fort en ce
moment ces lycées les émissions
mondiales de méthane ça augmente en fait
essentiellement par des fuites de gaz
fossile mais aussi par certaines
activités agricoles d'élevage et autres
et agir rapidement sur le méthane ça
peut présenter pas mal de bénéfices il
reste seulement une dizaine d'années
dans l'atmosphère donc si on baisse les
émissions on en a les effets rapidement
sur le climat le méthanier c'est aussi
en fait un précurseurs de l'ozone en
surface qui fait des pics d'ozone et qui
pose des problèmes en fait de pollution
atmosphérique et donc si on des carbone
donc on sort des énergies fossiles et
qu'on baisse en même temps les émissions
de méthane là vraiment on maximise les
effets positifs en termes de santé
publique et cette semaine il ya
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des journaux de
médicaux du monde et journaux
scientifiques médicaux qui ont lancé un
appel en disant pour nous en termes de
santé publique il ya des enjeux majeurs
à agir par rapport au climat par rapport
à la biodiversité et pour améliorer
aussi la qualité de l'air
mais ça ça se retranscrit pas
concrètement encore en action efficace
et à l'échelle nécessaire au genou à nos
copains les militaires les militaires il
posait quoique mais question alors les
militaires il pose un certain nombre de
questions qui sont par exemple liés à
quelles peuvent être les implications du
recul de la glace de mer en arctique par
rapport aux tensions géopolitiques dans
le secteur donc des ressources nouvelles
potentiellement disponibles et c'est pas
simple plus besoin non pas seulement ça
les ressources empêche un des enjeux
d'un climat qui change c'est que ça
affecte l'océan l'océan se réchauffe il
ya des vagues de chaleur marine plus
fréquente c'est ce qui flingue les
récifs de coraux tropicaux pas ce qui
les dégradent plus elles sont fréquentes
plus est les abîmes l'océan et
s'acidifient conséquence directe de nos
émissions et quand ils se réchauffent
l'eau de mer elle stagne en surface ou
le de se mélanger et on perd de
l'oxygène tout ça ça affecte la vie
marine et on s'attend à la poursuite
d'une baisse du potentiel de prises de
pêche en particulier dans les régions
tropicales il ya un tas de gens dans le
monde qui dépendent des protéines issues
des produits de la mer pour la sécurité
nutritionnelle et alimentaire donc les
tensions pour l'article c'est pas faut
pas imaginer que ce soit seulement pour
les minerais ou les énergies fossiles
c'est aussi en fait beaucoup d'acteurs
stratégique du secteur de la pêche en
particulier en asie qui voit l'arctique
comme une des zones potentiellement
importante pour préserver l'industrie de
la pêche et les effets associés donc
c'est un des exemples d autres exemples
porte gestion d autres questions qui
posait c'était quoi d'autre c'est un
exemple parmi d'autres d'autres portent
sur l'évolution du cycle de l'eau des
moussons d'afrique de l'ouest est ce que
cela peut impliquer sûr parce que tu
décris vais sur par exemple la
cohabitation entre des éleveurs nomades
et des agriculteurs sédentaires ainsi la
pression sur l'eau si on a des débuts de
moussons plus tardif si on a des
variabilités plus fort des sécheresses
plus sévère qu'est ce que ça peut
impliquer en termes de tension régionale
et on sait que l'augmentation local de
sécheresse quoi ya pas un cadre de
gouvernance pour l'accès à l'eau c'est
une source de tension très forte alors
cessé marron
un jour j'ai eu une discussion avec des
militaires et des gens qui travaillent
chez total
on et des mous les avais gibeau ligne et
un peu tu connais le gibolin non c'est
la boisson qui délie les langues
et on les a faits discuter et
un militaire qui dit orages c'est
dramatique les océans se réchauffent ça
fait péter la glace de méthane
vert vient vers le pôle nord
l'art nous ça nous affole pas ce qu'on
croyait encore que c'était les russes
qu'ils aient des expériences sous marine
de bombes nucléaires
et le mec de chez total dit oui ça nous
pose des problèmes parce que ça pète le
réchauffement de l'eau les fais péter
donc ça fait des grosses grosse
détonation sous l'eau est en fait après
ça relâche énormément de méthane dans
l'atmosphère donc là en début d'émission
tu m'as dit les océans se réchauffent et
va y en avoir encore pour longtemps sur
la glace de méthane qu'est ce qui se
passe en termes de ce prospectiviste sa
se passe bien ça se passe pas bien les
hydrates de méthane sait comment là
alors il ya plusieurs manières donc là
ce dont on parle c'est des formes de
stockage de méthane dans des sédiments
marins sous forme d'hydrates de méthane
qui sont à situés à des profondeurs
différentes et qui vont être
potentiellement affectés par part
peut-être des autres maires un peu plus
chaude à des moments différents donc
dans l'évaluation qu'on en a aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose pour lequel on est
on n'anticipe pas un effet amplificateur
majeure à l'échelle de ce siècle là où
il ya des choses plus claires c'est du
côté des sols gelés de l'arctique donc
les singes ours le permafrost ou
pergélisol en france est donc en fait
dans le passé il ya eu des phases plus
chaudes et de la matière organique qui
s'est accumulée du fait de la végétation
passé et puis c'est resté gelé pendant
un moment j'aimerais ça peut être donc
quand ça dégèle c'est pas ça pète pas
assez graduel donc on s'attend par
degrés de réchauffement supplémentaire à
perdre en gros un quart des sols gelés
sur 3 mètres de profondeur de l'arctique
et on a maintenant des estimations un
peu plus fine qu'avant de ce que ça peut
faire sur les émissions de co2 on le
prend en compte par exemple quand on dit
qu'est ce que c'est notre marge de
manoeuvre résiduelles il ya une relation
en fait étroite entre le cumul de nos
émissions passées présentes et futures
de co2 et le réchauffement actuel et à
venir c'est le truc le plus clair et on
le prend en compte en fait la partie
combien va sortir des sols gelés pour
estimer finalement ben la marge de
manoeuvre qui nous reste en terme
d'émissions humaine compte tenu de ce
qui va se passer du côté des sols gelés
et autres choses pour arriver à limiter
le réchauffement à un niveau
comme l'indiquent l'accord de paris sur
le climat un choix politique les
hydrates de méthane vous avez vous
informations doux alors c'est des
informations issues de l'ensemble des
travaux scientifiques qui portent là
dessus publiées dans la littérature
scientifique sachant que plus on va
naviguer en arctique plus on va observer
ce type de situation donc aujourd'hui on
navigue plus parce qu'à moins de
banquise on observe davantage mais ça
veut pas dire que ça s'accentue et quand
on regarde l'évolution des flux de
méthane on a un réseau de stations
autour de l'arctique c'est pas ça qui
domine aujourd'hui le fait que des
émissions augmentent ça vient plutôt des
régions tropicales avec en particulier
des projets de gaz faut faire issu du
gaz fossile et des rejets issus
d'activités d'élevage ou en tout cas sur
la dernière décennie c'est ça qui tirent
les émissions la concentration de
méthane à la hausse dans l'atmosphère il
y militer a voulu d'avoir des questions
dignes d'une première année à sciences
po vous avez des questions un peu plus
tôt tout flux ou c'était moi j'avais été
particulièrement impressionné par les
questions qui étaient posées par les
amiraux qui avaient beaucoup navigué sur
les océans qui avaient beaucoup observé
et qui avait une vision vraiment des
enjeux à l'échelle planétaire pas
simplement pour les océans pour les
aspects géopolitiques liées à l'océan et
aussi pour les aspects qui touchent sur
le littoral pourquoi c'est important
parce que la plupart des infrastructures
stratégiques les ports les aéroports
beaucoup de grandes villes sont situées
sur le littoral et donc ils avaient
aussi réfléchir aux enjeux et aux
implications liées à la montée du niveau
des mers la montée du niveau des mers
ses 20 cm au 20e siècle c'est maintenant
au rythme de 3,7 mm par an sa hausse à
accélérer c'est un des trucs qui a
accéléré dans l'évolution récente du
climat et puis la montée du niveau des
mers ce siècle dans les siècles suivants
ça va vraiment dépendre des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre qu'on va faire mais
ça va monter et c'est pas simplement la
montée graduelle comme pour d'autres
choses ça veut dire que quand on a une
forte marée et une tempête importante
les records de haut niveau marin qui
était précédemment rares vont devenir de
plus en plus fréquents parfois annuelle
1 plusieurs fois par an ça va entraîner
une érosion des côtes sableuses et ça va
poser un certain nombre d'enjeux pour
tout ce qui est stratégique qui est sur
le littoral et quand je dis des enjeux
ça veut dire ben soit on fait des
ouvrages en dur mais on peut pas les
mettre partout c'est cher soit on gagne
sur la mer comme à monaco singapour
quand on est très riche soit on fait des
replis stratégiques et ça ça pose
comme la capitale de l'inde de
l'indonésie je crois jakarta parce qu'en
fait elle s'enfonce sous son propre
poids le niveau des mers monde glace est
pas tenable et donc comment on fait
c'est encore une question très
importante qui touchent à des enjeux de
justice sociale sur la montée du niveau
des mers pour le littoral qu'est-ce
qu'on protège ce qui est stratégique
un patrimoine culturel historique des
plus riches comment on fait avec les
plus vulnérables comment on fait pour
que le positionnement de chacun soient
entendus face participe de la
délibération
comment est ce qu'on fait si on doit
déménager
faire ce repli stratégique pour le faire
de manière partagée il ya des enjeux
majeurs en fait on ne fait que à peine
en parler aujourd'hui mais graduellement
ça va être quelque chose qui va être de
plus en plus d'actualité et c'est ce que
j'entends moi quand je parle de
d'anticipation d'adaptation à un climat
qui change et certains militaires l'ont
bien compris ils l'ont bien compris et
regarde des villes en inde par exemple
avec tous ces enjeux de bidonvilles de
quartiers très aisés construites sur des
zones marécageuses qui s'enfonce le
niveau des mers qui montrent comment ça
va être géré il parle un peu du cold
stream ont pas du tout le golf stream
qui s'arrête il parle de ses un peu ou
pas du tout alors ça c'est les questions
qui nous reviennent souvent parce que
pas les militaires en fait mais il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se forme sur le
climat en regardant des films
d'hollywood et donc à chaque fois nous
on est obligé de rappeler la physique
des choses et puis il ya souvent une
question plus large sur voilà nombre sur
le col string ce n'était pas le scénario
d'hollywood c'était des gens partent
chez vous qui disait que quand même le
volume le courant se ralentissait les
taux à son plus bas depuis 1600 ans
barça c'est une publication scientifique
du mois de juillet qu'on n'a pas évalué
elle est arrivée tard par rapport à
notre évaluation très bonnes réponses ce
que je peux juste dire c'est que on a
des mesures dit alors c'est pas un
gulfstream gauthrin c'est un cours en
surface c'est en gros liée à la rotation
de la terre c'est pas ça en fait qui
compte pour le climat et ça va persister
ce qui compte c'est en fait la
circulation un espèce de grand tapis
roulant en surface et en profondeur de
l'océan atlantique qu'on appelle la
circulation méridienne de retournement
on le mesure directement depuis une
vingtaine d'années avec des réseaux
d'observation on voit en fait une
variabilité sur ces derniers 20 ans peut
pas conclure les estimations utilisées
sur le temps non c'est des choses
indirecte en fait par rapport à l'état
de surface de l'océan qu'on estime par
des indices dans les archives naturelle
du climat c'est pas la même chose et
dans notre évaluation ce qu'on montre c
comprenant compte tous les informations
disponibles elles sont pas cohérentes on
peut pas conclure s'il ya une tendance
en ce moment par contre dans tous les
modèles de climat quand ça se réchauffe
cette circulation se ralentit on peut
pas exclure que ça s'effondre et ça fait
partie des choses qu'on aborde sous
l'angle
possibilité à faible probabilité
d'occurrence mais potentiellement très
fort impact que ça j'explique on peut
pas dire dans quelles conditions ça va
se produire quel niveau de réchauffement
qu'on ne peut pas l'exclure parce que ça
s'est produit par fois dans le passé et
puis ça peut se produire aussi dans le
futur mais n'est pas forcément confiance
dans leur présentation des processus
dans nos modèles par contre ce qu'on
peut faire c'est artificiellement le
provoquer on rajoute beaucoup d'eau
douce dans un modèle de climat autour de
l'océan atlantique nord et on peut
provoquer en fait artificiellement un
arrêt de cette circulation elle prend on
regarde les conséquences tu regardes
aussi dans les crimes à passer ce qui
s'est produit dans le passé pour des
événements similaires et là les
conséquences elles sont très nets ans et
des conditions beaucoup plus sèche en
europe c'est des changements dans la
répartition des bandes de pluies dans
les régions tropicales des effets
directs sur les moussons voilà donc nous
ont fourni cette information ne peut pas
dire la probabilité qu'elle se produise
il ya plein d'aspects similaire pour le
climat par exemple un effondrement de
certains secteurs de l'antarctique qui
pourrait conduire à une augmentation
peut être deux fois plus forte que le
scénario le plus haut du niveau des mers
ce siècle
on sait que ces processus peuvent
exister non c'est pas les seuils de
réchauffement l'horizon temporel auquel
ça peut se produire mais pour la
première fois on peut quantifier dans ce
rapport si ça se déclenche en ce que ça
peut faire en plus et on le fourni et
pourquoi on le fait c'est pas qu'une
question de militaires en fait beaucoup
en fait de gestionnaires
d'infrastructures critiques qui prennent
des décisions qui sont sûres du temps
long l'aménagement des villes côtières
dans les pays émergents c'est un enjeu
pas pour 20 ans et pour du temps très
long
la soutenabilité des villes une ville
comme new york d'autres c'est une
question majeure en fait les villes
côtières qui concentre les activités
économiques pour leur attractivité aussi
et donc on nous demande aussi nous cette
information là on nous demande pas
simplement là valeureux dans laquelle on
a le plus confiance la moyenne de notre
distribution on nous demande de regarder
les codes distribution les événements
potentiellement rare mais qui auront le
plus d'impact possible et ça vous me
trouverez dans notre rapport au passé la
parole à pierre je vais lui une question
internet que je ne comprends pas donc
peut-être que tu vas la comprendre
question les grandes entreprises
françaises sont obligés de faire leur
bilan carbone mais que sur le scope 1 et
2 80% de leurs émissions sur le scope
sont sur le scope 3 lames en d2
attention les oreilles dix mille euros
si elles ne respectent pas l'obligation
ça c'est pas de la bonne rigolade
partie de la question ça c'est un cadre
réglementaire je peux pas tellement
commenté en fait 1 sur le fait de en
plus de transmettre des informations sur
ses pas la santé économique de
l'entreprise et une obligation d'être
transparent sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais effectivement par
exemple si vous vendez des produits
pétroliers vous avez en amont au moment
de l'exploration vous avez votre propre
activité interne de transport par
exemple de paraffine âge ou autre puis
après vous avez le ce qu'on appelle le
scope 3 c'est quand vous vendez vos
produits vos clients ils brûlent le
pétrole le gaz est en fait le gros des
émissions et l'a donc effectivement il
ya parfois des ambiguïtés et il ya
parfois une ce qui peut être perçu comme
une déresponsabilisation des entreprises
ans par rapport aux implications de
leurs produits de leurs stratégies
économiques sur l'ensemble du périmètre
des activités
et quand on prend le premier facteur
d'évolution du climat
l'augmentation de la teneur en co2 de
l'atmosphère 80 à 90% de sa c'est brûler
du pétrole du charbon du gaz et le reste
c'est détruire les tourbières détruire
des forêts en fête à
la question c'est est ce que une amende
de 10000 euros est-ce que c'est sérieux
ou est ce que c'est pour une entreprise
qui fait des milliards de chiffre
d'affaires effectivement ce n'est pas
suffisant ça n'est pas sérieux sur la
compris la gravité du problème du climat
et de la biodiversité on doit être
beaucoup plus
ambitieux et on a le même problème au
niveau européen on a fait ce qu'on
appelle une taxonomie d'entrée eu un
groupe de travail qui nomme et c'est
important c'est une étape importante on
avait donc qu'est ce qui est bon pour la
planète qu'est ce qui pollue qu'est-ce
qui est marron quels sont les énergies
sales et voilà en taxonomie et nous ce
qu'on dit c'est que ça il suffit pas
d'en rester là il faudrait interdire
complètement les ce qui est mauvais pour
la planète et on n'est pas les seuls à
le dire il ya eu le rapport de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie
en juin c'était un électrochoc pour
beaucoup de temps parce que l' agence
internationale de l'énergie à 10 ans
était un peu ou 15 ans le porte parole
du lobby pétrolier voilà c'était hélas
il ya une prise de conscience qu'ils ont
écrit cette année est incroyable il
insiste sur la gravité du problème
climatique et dit ce qu' il faut
immédiatement arrêter les nouveaux
investissements dans les énergies
fossiles et qu'il faut mettre trois
mille milliards chaque année en plus au
niveau mondial trois mille milliards
d'investissements dans l'isolation des
bâtiments dans les transports en commun
dans la dans l'efficacité avoir besoin
de moins d'énergie et voilà donc c'est
plutôt et c'est pas je le répète des
climatologues qui est de 10 2 c ou d
greenpeace et l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie aie trois semaines après il ya
tous les ministres de l'environnement et
de l'énergie qui se retrouvent à
bruxelles et il ya onze pays qui lisent
bah oui
les climatologues nous alertent la l
agence internationale on va stopper des
énergies fossiles pendant pendant padres
que moi et la france et manolo et la
france et la france n'en fait pas partie
même la ministre allemande même la
ministre belge mana ministre
luxembourgeois this on veut tendre eu le
toupet on peut stopper immédiatement les
énergies fossiles et la france regarde
ailleurs question internet y est il ne
serait ce qu'un pays qui respecte ses
engagements climatiques depuis les
accords de paris
alors en fait ça fait l'objet d'un suivi
qui est par le programme des nations
unies pour l'environnement qui rompt
tous les ans au mois de novembre ce
qu'ils appellent le nganga prix porte en
fait sur le décalage entre ce qu'on
devrait faire si on voulait être
cohérent avec l'accord de paris sur le
climat et puis les engagements pris par
les pays et leur réalité et si je me
souviens bien ma lecture du rapport de
l'année dernière c'est que il ya
peut-être une vingtaine de pays et je
crois qu'ils ont une action concrète qui
a permis d'atteindre une vingtaine ou
une trentaine de pays qui a permis
d'atteindre un pic d'émissions et de
diminuer par contre sur le suivi précis
par rapport aux promesses de 2015 et à
leur mise en oeuvre c'est pas quelque
chose qui est évident et je pense que ce
sera rendue encore plus délicat par un
effet de la pandémie et j'ai très peur
que certains finalement utilise la
baisse transitoire dû aux mesures pour
freiner la pandémie pour se dire non à
tenir nos engagements alors si on prend
le cas de la france par exemple la
france elle s'est dotée de budget
carbone sur plusieurs années à partir de
2015 le premier budget carbone il n'a
pas été tenu et le deuxième il a été
revu à la baisse parce que c'était hors
envisager qu'ils seraient pas tenus
voilà donc ça donne un peu une idée de
l'absence ans est dorée aux d'ambition
en n'ayant pas tenu le premier budget
carbone du pays hôte de l'accord de
paris sur le climat a été coupé par la
question internet
tout à l'heure c'est quoi si on tient
compte des âmes des produits qui
viennent de chine et d'ailleurs c'est le
gratuit non mais pas dans ces luttes
pour dire on n'est pas là pour rigoler
lors génétique selon le bilan le bilan
du co2 émis sur le territoire national a
effectivement baissé en france mais
c'est le des chiffres du ministère de
l'environnement publié dans les échos
qui disent que si on tient compte des
produits importés de chine ou d'ailleurs
il n'y a eu aucune baisse je suis désolé
de le dire sinon je serais très heureux
de dire que ça va mieux il n'y a eu
aucune baisse du bilan carbone complet
de la france dont il a besoin d'un
changement radical faut arrêter les
rustines faux est-ce que tu peux me dire
la source de tout pile source dehors
c'est les documents du plf d'ailleurs le
projet de loi de finances 2010 insee
eurostat publiée dans les échos
france et pour le climat alors sur
comment réduire l'empreinte carbone de
la france voilà c'est pas un groupe de
complotiste c'est le ministère de
l'environnement et le conseil qui lisent
hélas le bilan complet nom n'a fait
aucun progrès donc il faut changer
radicalement de braquet on était capable
de le faire mais ce qui m'énerve c'est
dans plein de domaines on a fait des
changements radicaux on a tous des
téléphones portables c'est
c'est pas en améliorant le vieux
téléphone affiche on a eu un saut
technologique en matière médicale j'ai
une copine qui est médecin qui travaille
sur les cancers de l'enfant elle dit
qu'elle a fait des progrès fabuleux pour
soigner les cancers de l'enfant est par
contre sur le climat ont fait des beaux
discours en mai des rustines mon père va
la catastrophe est donc tout à l'heure
valérie par les deux points je voulais
souligner dans ce cas dit valérie
premièrement ça coûterait pas tellement
cher d'agir par rapport à ce que ça nous
coûte l'inaction les centaines de morts
et les milliards de dégâts je redonne
les ordres de grandeur quand nicolas
hulot a démissionné nicolas il disait je
voudrais 7 milliards chaque année 7
milliards pour isoler des bâtiments
faire des transports en commun on l'a 10
7 milliards c'est pas possible je
rappelle que la banque centrale
européenne en une journée a créé 1300
milliards d'euros 1300 milliards qu'on a
donné aux banques à taux négatifs voilà
je rappelle aussi que quand le parlement
européen je suis pas le seule demande
une taxe sur la spéculation
on a refait les calculs malgré le break
site et malgré la crise une petite taxe
à 0 1% on aurait presque 60 milliards au
niveau européen ça ferait 10 milliards
qui arriverait en france est ce qu'on
savait qu'on avait dix milliards qui
arrivent en france on prend une vraie
loi climat donc vraiment ils n'ont
aucune excuse le diagnostic il est clair
le fait qu'on va vers le chaos si on
change pas c'est une évidence le fait
qu'on pourrait vivre bien si on avait
tous des maisons isolées ont pré vivre
bien dépenser moins d'énergie a moins
d'argent qui est dans les caisses de
monsieur poutine je rappelle aussi que
du point de vue bêtement économique on a
des dizaines de milliards sud voilà des
dizaines de milliards qui partent dans
les pays pétroliers dans les pays gazier
donc c'est bon pour le pouvoir d'achat
des gens c'est bon pour les créations
d'emplois on a tous les maires ruraux de
france qui nous soutiennent l'action
qu'on a lancé jean jouzel pour avoir des
vrais financement tous les maires ruraux
disent nos villages sont en train de
crever on voit les problèmes du
dérèglement climatique
on ne voudrait créer des emplois donc
ils n'ont aucune excuse et de valérie
lisez que comme citoyenne elle votait
souvent pour le moins pire tu l'as dit
sami tchéquie libre et je le redis il ya
des élections dans neuf mois tout ce
qu'on a dit ce tout et solution comporte
c'est pas emmanuel macron qui va les
mettre en oeuvre emmanuel macron eu tous
les pouvoirs depuis quatre ans il ne l'a
pas fait c'est pas macron c'est pas
marine le pen c'est pas les aviez
bertrand donc je pense qu'il est
fondamental qu'on obtienne la primaire
populaire qu'on se rassemble qu'une
équipe et qu'on arrive à changer les
choses et qu'on mette il ya des millions
de gens qui en ont marre et des millions
de gens qui voient qu'on regarde le
chaos social et le chaos climatique
on est des millions à vouloir rompre
avec les politiques mises en place
depuis 40 ans et on est vraiment stupide
je ne sais pas profitez des élections
pour changer de politique et je pense
qu'on peut le faire la france les
citoyens ont déjà provoqué des surprises
dans l'histoire de la france je pense
qu'il faut compris une surprise pour le
mois d'avril prochain et aller sur le
site primaire populaire point fr
aventure la folie tu as vu le film
d'albert dupontel adieu les coûts oui
oui
j'avais rivasi moi je voulais dire en
fait on parlait tout à l'heure des des
obligations de transparence et donc pour
moi c'est important que ces chiffres là
soient connus c'est à dire le bilan des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
l'échelle d'une ville d'une région de la
france d'une entreprise que ce soit
transparent et que tout un chacun puisse
se l'approprier et
exigeait aussi une action plus
importante donc il ya un travail à faire
je pense pour que ces informations
soient de plus en plus partagée et
qu'elles deviennent en fait une des
grilles d analyse des politiques
publiques des ambitions public et un
besoin vraiment de partage d'accès à
l'information c'est quelque chose qui
manque beaucoup aujourd'hui là dessus
question pour vous 2 question d'internet
finalement le transhumanisme et la
conquête spatiale hâtive c'est pas la
solution
c'est une question provoque
dix minutes de vacances dans l'espace
bon maintenant
ce sera fait du biogaz de machin attise
les routes belges on y croit oui qu'est
ce que je peux dire si c'est l'émulation
la concurrence entre les milliardaires a
qui s'en verra en l'air le plus haut
possible tout seul et en remerciant les
clients de son entreprise de lui
permettre de le faire je suis pas sûr
que c'est ça qui permettra le progrès de
l'humanité voilà et ça pose la question
de ce qui fait rêver les gens ça pose la
question de ce qu'est ce que c'est la
vision du progrès qu'est-ce que ça pose
aussi la question de comment on surmonte
cette espèce d'enfermement planétaire
puisque en tête on doit faire avec cette
planète on sera là on pourra pas non
s'installer sur notre planète va sortir
le syndrome de l'île déserte exactement
tu me disais donc ça joue sur un animal
qui il faut expliquer je t'en prie alors
je t'en prie alors ça dépend de la
vision militaire et la vision romanesque
qu'elle romanesque romanès non fiabilité
alors
imaginez vous tous on est sur un bateau
dans les caraïbes brassart vieux bateau
et puis mon pote à ma gauche il sait pas
conduire mais non plus et puis on se
prend un rocher et puis on arrive sur
une île déserte et sur l'île déserte ya
trois cocotiers 5 crabe et quelques
petits buissons il ya deux solutions
soit on reste là on attend comme des
cons là bas taux passe à n'avions pas on
fait des signes sur la plage et on mange
notre ordre croco tinou 5 crabe et notre
petit pulsion après plus rien et puis on
crée de la bouche ouverte puis la
deuxième prospective qui est on est
conscient qu'on a des ressources
limitées on a deux solutions soit on
bute pierre paul et jacques que si on a
de quoi tenir un peu plus longtemps
ce manque de solidarité entre pauvres
monpierre inquiétant a pas tuer tout de
suite tu vas tu mangeais d'avenches
héhéhé
soit on prend tous les paniers ont fait
rage au plus bas est-ce que les
milliardaires mégalo qu'on a à l'heure
actuelle ou syndrome de l'île déserte
je peux pas répondre à la question mais
ce que je trouve assez aversion au
risque
non je
en fait je suis pas sûr que ça réponde
vraiment à la question parce qu'en fait
on n'est pas dans une situation de
bateaux on n'est pas dans une situation
d'absence de ressources et on n'est pas
sur une situation
on a une échappatoire en fait donc là à
mon avis ça contribue à quelque part
comment dire quelque chose qui nous
rassure l'idée que peut-être on va
trouver une solution technologique qui
permettra à certains d'échapper aux
changements structurels pour aborder les
réels problèmes dont moi même que je le
vois dans le narratif dans la
possibilité le fait que ça capte
l'attention à ce point là au niveau
mondial c'est que ça joue sur des
mécanismes un peu inconscient de déni ou
d'inaction voilà donc c'est cette espèce
d'illusion moi qui me frappe
complètement d'accord là aussi avec
valérie mais moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
pas les milliardaires c'est dans la tête
c'est l'inaction de nos politiques c'est
pas les milliardaires qui doivent guider
une société je suis d'un parti qui
s'appelle nouvelle donne en référence au
new deal de roosevelt quand roosevelt
arrive le pays était sinistrée par la
crise d'après 1929 en trois mois il fait
passer 15 réformes fondamentales il fait
la séparation des banques qui fait un
impôt sur les plus riches parce qu'il
veut créer des millions d'emplois et les
milliardaires sont furieux les
milliardaires de l'époque explique
roosevelt est un communiste qui va tuer
l'amérique mais vous n'êtes pas là
l'intelligence des citoyens il a les
citoyens avec lui y compris parfois liés
aux citoyens à aller dans la rue j'ai
besoin que vous soyez nombreux pour
m'aider à faire reculer le lobby
bancaire et roosevelt fait passer des
réformes qui sont un succès et il a été
réélu et au moment où l'europe allait
vers la barbarie roosevelt avec sa
politique la sauver il a sauvé la
cohésion sociale les sauver la
démocratie donc et c'est pas les
milliards d un les milliardaires il se
trouve que quand on a créé le collectif
roosevelt petit-fils roosevelt était
avec nous il nous a raconté comment les
milliardaires de l'époque détester son
grand père mais son grand père savait
qu'il avait la bonne boussole c'était la
justice sociale et tout le monde
comprenait que le roosevelt travailler
pour le bien commun et le peuple et avec
lui et tenez bon donc le fait qu'il ya
des milliardaires qui va dans le délire
qu'ils soient prêts à dépenser des
sommes colossales pour avoir vu trois
minutes en apesanteur à ses yeux
ridicule le bilan carbone il faudrait
taxer beaucoup plus le kérosène encore
il ya trois jours je suis intervenu au
parlement peut-être pas taxer le
kérosène mais c'est ce qui m'inquiète
c'est pas c'est martin luther king qui
disait le mal qu est dans le monde ne
peut pas se comprendre sans l'inertie
des gens de bien ce que je vis martin
luther king le faisait mieux que ça mais
où il ya quelqu'un qui qui n'agit pas
contre le mal tu avais dit qu'il coopère
avec lui donc mon problème n'est pas les
milliardaires mon problème est comment
est ce qu'on a on accepte que des
politiques qui n'ont pas les bonnes des
bonnes actions on les laisse au pouvoir
et comment se connaît assez bête pour ne
pas se rassembler pour changer les
choses c'est ça ce qui me pousse à agir
pur bonheur ni moi j'ai une autre aussi
vision là dessus c'est celle en fait de
l'espace bien commun et il ya des enjeux
qui sont très importants le fait de
disposer de suivi par satellite de
l'état en permanence de l'atmosphère et
puis du reste de la machine climatique
c'est quelque chose qui est essentiel
c'est essentiel pour suivre l'évolution
du climat c'est essentiel pour
comprendre comment ils fonctionnent à
terme par exemple discerner si on a plus
de méthode méthane qui sort de telle ou
telle zone on n'y est pas encore mais on
peut le faire mieux comprendre les
nuages et leur rôle dans climat s'est
encore associé à une incertitude
importante c'est essentiel pour les
systèmes précoce d' alerte pour pouvoir
se mettre à l'abri les progrès ils ont
été considérables en fait sur la
prévision météorologique et
l'observation depuis l'espace
l'intégration des données en temps réel
dans les systèmes de prévision
météorologique c'est quelque chose qui
est fondamental et le fait de plus en
plus d'avoir également une privatisation
de l'espace des norias de petits
satellites et leurs dégâts c'est quelque
chose qui pose problème en fait qui va
peut-être
diminuer notre capacité d'observation de
la terre et donc pour moi l'espace n'est
pas simplement quelque chose ou on va
faire du tourisme si on est plein
d'argent puis on racontera sa ses amis
parce que l'antarctique s'est trop près
en fait est un peu de ça quand même sert
le tourisme un peu ultime pour quand on
a les moyens faire quelque chose qui a
un impact carbone énorme pour pouvoir
s'en vanter quasiment pour moi c'est
passé à l'espace c'est quelque chose qui
nous appartient à tout ce qui est
associé aux progrès technologiques aux
progrès des connaissances et qui demande
aussi des cas qui posent des questions
de gouvernance qui sont importants
ces questions incluent d'ignorer dans
pas très longtemps et pire tu veux
rajouter quelque chose
alors moi je vais je vais vous poser une
question
le capitalisme tel qu'on le connaît
est-ce que c'est pas une idéologie
tellement toxique
que on n'arrive même plus à le voir
est ce qu'on n'a pas contaminé tout le
monde sur terre avec une idéologie
tellement toxique qui va falloir
tellement d'années pour se rattraper
qu'on va se faire nous rattraper par le
réchauffement climatique
non moi je crois vraiment on est des
millions à comprendre la gravité de ce
qui se passe on et 2000 des millions à
se dire qu'un modèle économique qui
provoque autant de précarité et de
pauvreté de burn out il ya des gens qui
crèvent pas s'ils n'ont pas travaillé
puis en a qui crèvent parce qu'ils
travaillent trop un modèle économique il
faut en l'air la cohésion sociale mais
aussi la biodiversité et le climat c'est
pas un modèle c'est un non sens voilà et
donc je crois qu'on est des millions à
le comprendre partout on va faire des
débats avant le virus les salle était
archi plein les gens voulaient
comprendre et agir tous les jeunes qui
étaient dans la rue à madrid j'avais dit
neil de tes collègues climatologues
avait le traite et jean jouzel qui m'a
dit le seul truc énorme thémis et les
jeunes sont dans la rue et qui vont
obliger les politiques à agir donc je
crois moi je suis moins pessimiste que
que toi sky et je crois qu'on s'immisce
mais on est dans ce moment mais a priori
c'est foutu après j'ai rien vu en
arrivant à priori c'est foutu
l'accumulation de la crise climatique de
la crise sociale j'ai montré qu'on peut
avoir n'importe quand une nouvelle crise
économique le fmi dit on peut avoir une
crise dix fois plus grande qu'au début
c'est foutu pis mais le nommé par contre
mais comme on est des millions avoir un
cerveau y compris à regarder des trucs
intéressants sur les réseaux sociaux y
compris m mais ces [__] pour moi et
pour mes enfants j'ai pas envie d'aller
vers le chaos non mais sans rire je n'ai
je refuse qu'on aille vers le suicide du
robot je sais qu'il ya pas de baguette
magique je sais que ça va être compliqué
je sais qu'on va pas stopper en trois
jours le dérèglement climatique il faut
se relever mais mais que l'histoire de
l'humanité montre que c'est souvent
quand c'est très très grave que des gens
se remettent en mouvement dans mon
bureau à bruxelles tu viendras quand tu
veux j'ai la photo du mur de berlin et
puis j'ai une très belle phrase de
vaclav havel qui dit chacun tour juste
après que le mur de berlin est tombé
vaclav havel dit le peuple s'est
réveillée avec une rapidité
bouleversante quant à la boxe et
beaucoup n'ont pas la main le trou de
pouilly l'esma vaclav havel sega de
magnifiques le peuple s'est réveillée
avec une rapidité bouleversante il
veillait ils attendaient le moment
propice tous ceux qui ne mentait pas
dans leur vie quotidienne ont apporté
leur contribution et vaclav havel dit
chacun de nous peut changer le monde
même s'il croit qu'il n'a pas la moindre
importance chacun de nous peut changer
le monde et c'est déjà une misère à ces
gens sans importance et des gens comme
toi et moi c'est pas gorbatchev c'est
pas une moue de colle qui ont fait
tomber le mur de berlin c'est des gens
comme qui se dit [__] j'en ai marre de
cette vie je veux vivre libre je veux
vivre heureux que mes enfants me veut
libre et ils ont fait tomber ils étaient
trois ils étaient trente étaient 3000
ont fait tomber le mur de berlin et je
crois aussi que aujourd'hui même si
l'ennemi est moins visible que le mur de
berlin mais que le système capitaliste
je répète il provoque autant de pauvreté
et d'inégalité on est tous choqués quand
tu débutes me mélanie c'est un système
qui est gouverné uniquement par le fric
pour les plus riches et c'est notre
incapacité à le changer on aura tout
pour vivre un pays de cocagne on n'a
jamais été aussi riche humainement
dimanche je donne ma parole à valérie et
tu prends la parole et donc chacun de
nous c'est raide tout seul chef d'état
parlant 30 secondes si chacun j'allais
cela va prendre 30 secondes si on reste
chacun chez soi à lire le rapport du
giec a dit ah [__] c'est foutu à voir
les courbes du fmi à dire c'est foutu
voilà il ya de quoi effectivement se
flinguer mais si on se rassemble pour
réfléchir et pour agir ensemble je pense
qu'on peut gagner la partie
en fait moi je veux pas complètement
adressé ta question mais mentionner que
il ya eu des expériences de système
communiste à parti unique totalitaire
productiviste qu'on conduit à des
catastrophes environnementales également
donc voilà c'est juste pour nuancer la
suivre ou l'union soviétique en fait à
l'époque en sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
d'autres choses s'étaient pas
particulièrement remarquables en voilà
et donc ça pose des questions et sous
l'angle en fait de l'impact des
activités humaines sur l'environnement
planétaire le terme qui est souvent
utilisé c'est celui dans troppo scène
pour essayer de discerner à partir de
quel moment finalement la longue
histoire de l'humanité elle s'est mise a
déraillé et on a commencé à voir une une
empreinte en fait sur notre
environnement disproportionnée
finalement alors certains le date du
moment de l'invention de la machine à
vapeur finalement qui a permis avec
l'utilisation des énergies fossiles de
changer complètement le système
énergétique
le rapport au travail et puis bah par
l'utilisation croissante d'énergie
fossile de conduire à la situation que
sur laquelle on dit d'autres sur par
exemple le rôle des humains pour
disperser des espèces vivantes d'un
continent à l'autre met en évidence le
début du commerce triangulaire comme
jouant un rôle fondamental finalement
sur les échanges disproportionné entre
les continents et leurs effets à échelle
planétaire et puis d'autre en fait
mettre en évidence un poids croissant du
capitalisme financier effectivement avec
une vision à très court terme qui perd
complètement toute relation avec les
conséquences à long terme puisque on
paye pas pour les dommages qui sont
considérés qui
met à mal la gouvernance de long terme
dans chaque pays par rapport au bien
commun voilà donc ce sont ses angles là
qu'on peut utiliser aussi pour lire mais
c'est pas simplement à mon sens une
histoire de système purement capitaliste
c'est une question de gouvernance
ensemble et en prenant en compte le long
terme il ya quelques expériences
intéressantes que je veux mentionner
comment on prend en compte le long terme
je sais que dans certains pays' avait
fait l'expérience d'avoir un ministère
du futur pour chaque décision qu est ce
que ça implique sur le tendon qu'est ce
que ça implique chez pas pour l'énergie
pour les retraites quand
il ya d'autres endroits où on se rend
compte que c'est très difficile d'avoir
un débat démocratique sur des décisions
importantes à prendre aujourd'hui parce
que ses clients il y en a qui vont
perdre plus que d'autres qui ont
l'impression de perdre plus que d'autres
et donc c'est très clivant et dans
certains cas en fait on fait jouer aux
gens le rôle de leurs enfants ou de
leurs petits-enfants pour définir
ensemble sever on veut aller et après en
fait c'est plus facile de s'accorder sur
la manière d'y aller voilà donc je pense
que ça pose des vraies questions de fond
de prise de décision de gouvernance
au-delà de la réflexion sur les systèmes
économiques dans lesquels on fonctionne
des questions vraiment de fondre
démocratique on arrive à la fin de notre
interview n'a encore de 2,3 question est
ce que vous voulez qu'on rajoute
quelques chose est ce qu'on oublie
quelque chose
non non
alors vers le trou il ya des
connaissances peut-être mieux j'ai pas
entendu le progrès des connaissances le
progrès des connaissances pour aller où
c'est ça la question
on arrive à la fin de notre émission
pierre connaît déjà la dernière question
donc je vais te la pause et d'avoir un
toit valérie c'est pas une question
s'est laissé un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer
quelque chose d'impérissables qui va
rester sur les réseaux sociaux
et
pour le futur
qu'est ce que tu veux laisser dans cette
bouteille
et bien sûr il faut nous conseillez
trois bouquins trois bouquins maintenant
trois ans soutient maintenant à lire
quelque chose qu'on était qu'ils doivent
qui nécessaire
trois livres nécessaires et un conseil
pour les jeunes générations alors bien
évidemment certains aspects du rapport
du giec de 2021 par exemple les fiches
régional des questions fréquentes ans
qui sont relativement faciles d'accès ça
c'est la première chose
un livre d'un philosophe qui s'appelle
pierre charbonnier qui s'appelle
abondance et libertés pour réfléchir en
fait ce qui a finalement façonner la
manière dont nos sociétés occidentales
ont évolué avec le regard historique
philosophique ça ça fait deux faut que
je trouve le troisième j'ai besoin d'un
peu plus de temps d'accord alors un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
alain porte laisse un peu plus de temps
on va faire répond pire ouais mais s'ils
n'ont pas déjà peu fatigué soir moi je
voulais juste donner le conseil aux
jeunes générations c'est vraiment
engagez vous on peut prendre du plaisir
à être avec d'autres à se tenir debout à
réfléchir avait d'autres agir avec
d'autres on est vraiment d'un moment de
crucial en et d'un moment historique par
nial l'humanité ce qui va se passer en
france en europe dans les prochaines
années détermine notre vie pour les
années futures et on dit souvent que
c'est la jeunesse d'un pays qui fait
bouger des choses qui a beaucoup de gens
qui ont 40 ans 50 ans 60 ans qui ont
déjà été beaucoup déçu par les
politiques ils ont voté ils ont été
déçus ils ont été trahis s'intéresser à
la politique la jeune génération a moins
été trahis car d'une énergie fabuleuse
beaucoup de temps pour s'informer un
cerveau qui marche bien et moi je suis
un des rares truc qui me rend optimiste
c'est le tai chi à des milliers de
jeunes dans tous les pays d'europe qui
se sont mis en mouvement et j'espère
qu'ils vont pas s'arrêter et j'espère
qu'ils vont obliger les plus vieux à se
mettre en mouvement et agir et je le
répète ce n'est possible consciente
travaillent ensemble chacun dans son
coin ce sont désarmés at il ya de quoi
désespérer et se rassembler on peut y
avoir débat des victoires historiques
vraiment s'il vous plaît prenez du temps
avec dote pour agir faire des groupes
locaux voilà on a des solutions si vous
allez sur les réseaux sociaux je suis
pas le seul sur les diagnostics losc a
dit valérie fondamental il ya le rapport
du giec et sinon sur les solutions vous
pouvez sur nos réseaux sociaux il ya
plein de vidéos qui expliquent les
solutions et qui peuvent vous donner
envie de vous engager merci bien valérie
way la troisième lecture alors qu'on
s'est un peu technique mais le rapport
du haut conseil climat sur comment
réduire l'empreinte carbone de la france
il est intéressant parce que justement
il aborde la question en fonction des
revenus en fonction des relations
internationales et puis centré sur le
périmètre français et puis faire son
empreinte carbone c'est une façon de
rentrer dans un diagnostic disons
objectif de la situation puis ça permet
aussi de guider ce vers quoi on veut
agir donc ça c'est la partie ce que je
mets dans la bouteille en cas d'insomnie
c'est très bien toutes ces lectures 9 et
puis l'autre chose c'est la chose que je
voudrais dire ouais le conseil ces
dialogues et dialoguer et en particulier
pour beaucoup des plus jeunes vous avez
de la chance en fait vous avez la chance
d'avoir accès à l'information à
l'éducation les réseaux sociaux c'est
une mine d'informations formidable donc
par votre propre parcours vous
approprier des connaissances des
informations mais d'autres ne font pas
forcément cette démarche là et le
dialogue le faites vous même de porter
la discussion sur des enjeux liés au
climat d'écouter les remarques des
autres d'amener chacun à faire son
cheminement sa réflexion c'est quelque
chose qui est important et on voit
aujourd'hui comme comme ça a été dit on
est dans une société qui est parfois
très morcelé très éparpillé avec des
gens qui s'enferme dans des bulles de
gens qui pensent comme eux traverser les
bulles et avoir la capacité à créer un
dialogue c'est quelque chose qui est
essentielle
valérie pierre merci beaucoup d'être
venu nous voir merci merci
[Musique]
dans